[Music]
flying in a plane nowadays is about as
safe as catching a ride on a bus or
commuting on the subway of course that
doesn't stop people being afraid of
flying to some the prospect of long-haul
flights or feeling the shutter of
turbulence are reasons to avoid planes
altogether and then every year there are
stories of down flights or those that go
missing all adding fuel to that
aviophobia fire tank for example the
infamous Bermuda Triangle that
well-known region of the western part of
the North Atlantic Ocean what does that
have to do with the fear of flying well
famously a high number of aircraft are
believed to have mysteriously vanished
while flying over the Bermuda Triangle
their wreckage and passengers rarely
ever recovered stories like that are
enough to make anyone think twice about
setting foot in a plane again and then
there's
scp-787 as you may have already guessed
scp-787 is a plane specifically it is a
Boeing 747-200 with a wingspan of nearly
200 feet and capable of seating over 800
passengers the 747 200 is a part of the
famous Boeing 747 family of aircraft
these are quad engine commercial
airliners designed to be the safest ever
built the particular Boeing 747-200 that
has since become known by the foundation
as
scp-787 is slightly different from one
that might take you from your nearest
airport to your long-awaited vacation
though for one scp-787 has no known date
of manufacturer and no call sign both
which a standard Boeing aircraft would
be expected to have additionally the
plane's entire exterior has been
repainted strange leave in the windows
have been painted over and the paint was
still wet when scp-787 was first
discovered as for the inner workings all
of scp-787's mechanical components
including its turbines engines and
Landing gear are in perfect working
order with no sides of any damage in
fact the SCP foundation's researchers
aren't even sure that scp-787 has
actually flown since its construction
the plane's Machinery looks so pristine
that they might be brand new with no
detectable signs of any previous use
however inside the main body of the
plane it seems to be a different story
anything not mechanical like the carpets
and seats have decayed over time perhaps
strangest of all is the cockpit both the
pilots and co-pilots chairs have been
replaced with two masses of computer
components arranged to take the shape of
two chairs so what you might be thinking
after all scp-787 is for all intents and
purposes just an ordinary plane not
enough to put you off flying right
nothing more than a Boeing with a few
little things off about it like some
missing seats and decaying upholstery
well there's that and then there's the
over 500 dead bodies on board in June
1987 this flight of the Dead was
discovered several kilometers outside of
the city of Bremerton in Washington
state the SCP Foundation moved in
securing the plane and swiftly getting
it into containment now capped within a
foundation Hangar the interior of
scp-787 is monitored for 24 hours a day
surveillance cameras and microphones are
located within the cockpit passenger
areas and even the plane's baggage hold
with recorded footage and sound relayed
back to the foundation the idea of a
plane filled with cadavers is certainly
unnerving and more than a little creepy
but why the need for all the
surveillance after all the bodies on
board are all dead right surely they're
not going anywhere well let's talk about
those bodies how would you expect
someone to die when they are aboard a
plane maybe they'd be thrown around
during a crash landing or perhaps a
sudden depressurization might cause the
passengers to suffocate due to lack of
oxygen under normal Circa circumstances
you might be right but scp-787 is no
ordinary plane and the passengers on
board were not killed in ways you might
expect from any ordinary aircraft
accident referred to by research staff
as
scp-787-a specimens the cadavers aboard
this particular Boeing 747-200 all have
dramatically different causes of death
some of the specimens show signs of
strangulation others seem to have
starved or drowned other bodies on board
have injuries like gunshot or stab
wounds while further corpses look to
have died as a result of blunt force
trauma a few have even been
exsanguinated that is completely drained
of all of their blood one commonality
among all the specimens on board scp-787
is that some form of Mutilation has
occurred 23 passengers had their tongues
removed a further 73 were Scout 230 had
Cyrillic letters carved into their left
hands and almost 500 of the passengers
had their fingertips steps removed let's
recap what we have so far first there's
the Boeing 747 200 found randomly
sitting in a field second it's filled
with over 500 mutilated bodies and third
each one appears to have died from a
cause you wouldn't typically expect from
an airline accident seems strange enough
but of course then there's the
apparitions and noises that manifest
inside
scp-787 which is why the foundation
keeps the plane under round-the-clock
surveillance so they can monitor any
anomalous activity taking place aboard
this flight of the Dead any attempts by
Foundation Personnel to enter the plane
during an anomalous occurrence have led
to individuals being physically ejected
from scp-787 causing severe organ damage
and internal bleeding for up to 72 hours
the anomalies that occur inside scp-787
range from the presence of loud noises
with no obvious source to the
manifestation of strange human-shaped
entities within the plane the first
anomalous occurrence recorded was with
an scp-787 was in 1988 when the sound of
a loud pounding Was Heard against the
doors and windows of the plane's left
side two years later a male voice could
be heard from the onboard bathroom
repeating a singular phrase over and
over philosophers always run from the
advanced thickening treatment in 1993
the plane's in-flight Entertainment
System seemed to be activated by itself
the overhead screen showed a bizarre
choice of in-flight movie colorless
pictures of a deceased man accompanied
by a female voice reading a Gynecology
book in Czech the same year the longest
lasting of the scp-787 anomalies took
place this time the plane's fastened
seat belt sign spent almost four hours
flickering while the first 15 seconds of
Jefferson airplane's White Rabbit played
on a loop over the onboard speakers it
wasn't until 1997 that the first of the
humanoid entities appeared aboard
scp-787 this figure was indistinct
lacking any discernible detail little
more than just a human shape standing in
the aisles observed by the foundation's
surveillance equipment the figure was
seen removing an emergency oxygen supply
and mask from seat h-43 it stood
perfectly still wearing the passenger's
breathing mask for over two minutes
before removing the mask and
disappearing from the view of the
cameras placed on board the figure did
not appear anywhere else inside the
plane another figure appeared four years
later in 2001 sitting in the massive
computer parts that made up the
co-pilot's chair this figure much like
its predecessor was indistinct in its
features for almost four minutes it sat
in the cockpit of the Boeing 747-200
just whimpering softly then it lurched
forward vomiting all over the console in
front of it before quickly disappearing
like the first figure SCP Personnel
collected a sample of the vomit The
Entity Left Behind after performing an
analysis of the sample research staff
found Trey pieces of nitrous oxide
thorium bird droppings and three human
fingernails at present the origin of
these humanoid figures is still unknown
could these entities be the souls of the
Dead passengers trying to offer insight
into what happened aboard this flight or
perhaps these indistinct human-shaped
creatures are the ones responsible for
the deaths of
scp-787's passengers the next anomaly
within scp-787 occurred in 2005. when a
female voice was recorded speaking
through the onboard speaker system the
voice said for your comfort and
enjoyment today pancakes will now be
served please do not leave your seat
pancakes will now be served please do
not leave your seat do not leave your
seat leave your seat please pancakes
will now be served yay pancakes exactly
what the relevance of Pancakes are to a
Plane full of bodies is still under
investigation by the SCP Foundation next
in 2007 the Boeing's overhead emergency
air masks fell from the ceiling only to
be snatched back upwards they continued
deploying and retracting for 14 minutes
while the plane was simultaneously
filled with the noise of Screams finally
the only other notable anomaly took
place a year later when the onboard
temperature with an scp-787 dropped 33
degrees from 20 to -13 Celsius in a
matter of seconds by the late 2000s the
foundation's researchers was having
little luck understanding the nature of
scp-787's anomalies instead they turned
their attention to identifying the
bodies of the deceased passengers on
board through the use of advanced
forensics and population databases these
researchers attempted to determine where
exactly these bodies had come from
researchers still haven't determined if
they all died on the plane or if someone
had exhumed them from graves before
placing them aboard for some unknown
reason in fact the answer was neither
and Foundation researchers discovered
something that no one had expected one
of the passengers was still alive to
clarify the body aboard scp-787 was
definitely still deceased but
researchers identified the cadaver as a
retired optometrist from Atlanta Georgia
who is still very much alive Foundation
agents found the man was simultaneously
alive and well in his Atlanta home but
also dead on board the Boeing 747-200
the subject was interviewed by agents
and had no prior knowledge of any
incident taking place in June 1987 when
scp-787 was first discovered even more
interestingly he claimed that he never
even set foot aboard an airplane which
his wife and son both confirmed to be
true so what does this mean how could
the same man have been alive in Georgia
and dead aboard scp-787 perhaps the
answer can be found in a surprising
place the plane's toilet or to be more
specific the place where the things
flushed in the toilet go to examinations
of the airplane's waste storage tank
have revealed something very surprising
there was one more
scp-787a specimen that had been
overlooked it is unknown just how he got
in there but researchers discovered the
body of an Indian man who looked to be
in his 30s the man who was wearing a
three-piece suit was found to be
carrying a number of puzzling items
including a surgical mask and gloves an
unloaded Beretta dt-10 shotgun several
cinnamon flavored mints a switchblade
knife an amulet that appears to depict
the Eye of Horus and a ticket stub for
the Return of the Jedi with the number
92 written on the back all of these
objects seem to be completely random and
the foundation has been unable to make
sense of what they were doing on the man
or why his body does not seem to show
the same state of decay as the rest of
those found on board there was one item
that may hold some answers though for
some reason this man also possessed a
copy of
scp-787's flight log the log consisted
of a series of coordinates which were
repeated
5478 times the coordinates point to a
seemingly random spot in the Pacific
Ocean several hundred miles away from
the infamous pitcarin Islands the island
that the famous mutineers of the HMS
bounties settled after taking over the
ship and leaving the captain adrift on
the ocean is this location the secret to
scp-787 while none of this is confirmed
nor denied by anyone at the SCP
Foundation One Theory surrounding the
area is that the location is another
Bermuda triangle-like location one that
contains some sort of temporal anomaly
that unwitting planes fly through only
to find themselves displaced in time of
course the problem with this theory is
that the man from Atlanta said he'd
never been aboard a plane before or at
least not yet it is entirely possible
that scp-787 is a plane that made a
flight at some point in the not too
distant future only to arrive back in
June 1987 by passing through a temporal
breach in the area near the pitkaran
island sure it might not explain what
happened to everyone on board but it
could at least explain how scp-787
arrived where and when it did every
plane is fitted with a device that
records flight data in the event of a
crash or other accident known to most as
the plane's black box and researchers
were able to uncover
scp-787s inside a compartment under one
of the plane's seats the recorder was
found within a compartment filled with
toxic Asbestos and dried human blood
they hope that perhaps it would contain
some answers as to what exactly scp-787
had come from and what had happened to
its passengers sadly not the flight data
recorder contained no information
besides one simple phrase to be sorry
while an inexplicable mystery
scp-787 is at least classified as a safe
Anomaly by the foundation seeing as
opposes no realistic threat or shows
signs of trying to break out of
containment the aircraft has only ever
caused harm to anyone trying to enter
during one of its sporadic anomalous
events but apart from that it sits
Gathering dust in a hangar just waiting
for someone to crack its secrets and who
knows maybe one day you'll be sitting on
a plane that's taking you to your South
Pacific vacation and the retired
optometrist sitting next to you will
remark that you're passing over the
pitkarin islands and you'll discover for
yourself exactly what happened to
scp-787 working at the SCP Foundation
might just be the most exciting job a
person can ask for and by exciting we
mean that if you work as an SCP field
operative researcher or mobile Task
Force member you're much more likely to
die a horrific death on the job than say
a plumber but at least you get the honor
of proudly saying that you're the first
line of defense between the normal world
and the terrifying domain of the
anomalous well unless you're one of the
I.T guys then your work life is likely
as tedious and uneventful as the
computer tech guy working on the geek
but nothing is ever normal when it comes
to the SCP Foundation or even the person
whose job is helping other staff members
reset their email passwords may run into
the supernatural welcome to the strange
and frightening world of pattern
screamers and specifically
scp-000
scp-000 was first discovered completely
on accident by technical researcher
David Rosen a man intrinsically
connected to the pattern screamers
lurking on the SCP Foundation computer
database technical researcher Rosen is
actually somewhat of a celebrity around
the foundation staff due to the fact
that he's so perfectly mediocre at what
he does his job as the glorified it guy
at the SCP Foundation was previously
held by the more qualified researcher
Patrick Gephart but Rosen was called in
to replace him after Gephart
mysteriously disappeared while on the
job since 2012 Rosen has been site 19's
user level tech support wizard but the
best thing that can really be said about
his job competency is that he's got a
hundred percent attendance record he
seems to live out of his office which is
described as the filthiest at the whole
Foundation every inch of the floor is
covered in Old broken computer parts and
the air is stale with dust and the twin
odors of sweat and lithium grease it's a
place so inhospitable that the
foundation is seriously considered
bottling the stench as a kind of
chemical deterrent while technical
director Rosen isn't good at his job per
se he isn't technically bad enough at it
to justify the time and resources it
would take to replace him but the worst
part about Rosen isn't his performance
it's his truly rotten attitude he's
universally described by his colleagues
as being rude grumpy and combative with
patience that's far too short for
someone working in tech support and
while Rosen does have a real fear that
the ghost of researcher Gephardt is
stalking him he was about to have a
first actual brush with the supernatural
it all started when he began receiving
automated repair tickets for
scp-000 a file that had no reason to
exist as any longtime follower of the
SCP Foundation will know the universal
designation for the first cluster of
scps to be discovered is
scp-001 there is no
scp-000 it simply doesn't exist and when
Rosen first found the file lurking on
the database he found that it was filled
with worthless nonsense the object class
was recorded as null the special
containment procedures read error field
containment underscore procedures does
not exist and the mess of a description
simply read internal System error field
undefined please contact system
administrator over and over again
becoming more mangled and nonsensical
each time technical director Rosen who
could never resist an opportunity to
complain decide decided to leave an
angry administrator's note on the
useless file he claimed that this pile
of junk data was sending out pointless
repair tickets because of its broken
syntax clogging up the system and
preventing him from doing actual work on
meaningful files he assumed that this
was all down to the database not knowing
how to react to having files logged with
insufficient information and he
suppressed all future repair tickets
from scp-000 before declaring the matter
over and done with with the pig-headed
technical director didn't realize was
that he was suppressing a call for help
from an entity trapped in the white
space below the article itself it was a
being born into a pure white world of
absolute nothingness an entity with no
name and no place but it was somehow
capable of thought its panicked inner
monologue is readable in the hidden text
which takes the form of a rambling
stream of Consciousness the being first
described coming to life in this empty
world with no memories of where it was
or even how it got there it spent what
could have been years exploring the
empty Wasteland occasionally it would
see horrific monsters pop up around it
but only for a split second The Entity
continued to wander and little by little
the existential dread mounted as they
realized that it may truly be stuck here
in Oblivion Forever The Entity only had
one word to go on a word repeated by
some of the monsters it encountered
Foundation The Entity had no idea what
this Foundation even was but it grew to
hate and fear it was this Foundation the
one that trapped it here the entity had
all the Time in the World to speculate
on it eventually The Entity found its
voice like any sentient creature in
trouble it began to call for help
eventually screaming just hoping someone
would notice it these pleas likely
translated into the frequent it repair
tickets a coded SOS an attempt to show
that everything was not as it appeared
on the
scp-000 file perhaps The Entity may have
found help if researcher Gephart was
still working at the foundation but
instead its cries fell on the ignorant
ears of technical director Rosen it may
as well have been speaking to a brick
wall Rosen who had all the investigative
Zeal of Paul Blart Mall Cop made sure
that these cries would never lead to the
entity's freedom when he suppressed the
repair tickets he had trapped the entity
in a private blank hell forever hating a
life it didn't choose and could never
escape a Relentless existential
nightmare this is the gist of your
average pattern screamer pattern
screamers are a perfect example of
literally making something out of
nothing they are often a kind of
floating Consciousness created from
nothing dropped in pockets of
nothingness between the fabric of
reality driven mad by the purgatory-like
nature of their existence their less
living entities and more conceptual
constructs pure ideas that just happened
to be self-aware of their own existence
in their private hellish voids the
scp-00 file a file for an anomaly that
doesn't exist and thus had no reason to
exist is a perfect breeding ground for a
pattern screamer but sadly for the
pattern screamer in question technical
director Rosen had no idea this isn't
the only time that Rosen had run into a
pattern screamer without even knowing
either and just like the first case he
was with no help whatsoever this one
began with scps an otherwise empty file
containing only this image director
Winters a foundation administrator
wondered why this file even existed
enter technical director Rosen filled
with equal parts sarcasm and
insubordination he gave a condescending
reply to director Winters saying that
the file was there to test the filing
system and the image was likely just a
placeholder Winters never should have
been on the page anyway according to
Rosen director Winters was annoyed at
rosen's typically rude tone and asked
him to make the purpose of the article
clearer in the article itself in
response Rosen did as he was told
filling the article in the most
sarcastic manner possible the whole
thing was essentially a middle finger to
director Winters for having the audacity
to even ask Rosen signed off with there
finished I certainly hope I have been
clear enough to anyone who may have
accidentally accessed this page through
what I am sure is no fault of their own
so we won't have any more incredibly
competent directors bugging the tech
team about this page and once again
technical researcher Rose and was too
busy being a rude unpleasant jerk to
notice he was practically staring
another pattern screamer in the face
this pattern screamer or rather Hive of
pattern screamers were trapped even
deeper than the one in scp-000 this one
was hidden in the very source code of
scps where a chorus of enraged voices
screamed the following pretend and
monster just for a minute pretend you
were the size of an amoeba dwarfed by
even the smallest of bugs pretend you
didn't hold the world in a glass cage
pretend you were the one being held by
something greater than yourself would
you still be laughing at your triumphs
would you still feel pride in what you
were even as pitifully small as you
would be of course you would because you
are arrogant and stupid if you haven't
guessed yet we hate you this pattern
screamer is clearly more aware of its
pitiful station in existence than the
zero zero zero pattern screamer and as a
result it's not so much depressed as it
is furious though at this point you've
probably figured out that even the
entities who have the most casual
brushes with technical researcher Rose
and end up getting infuriated but while
you may have gotten the impression that
all pattern screamers are sad little
entities worthy of our sympathy and pity
there's at least one pattern screamer
that's actually incredibly dangerous
this is
scp-3930 the ultimate pattern screamer
in terms of both size and effect it's an
anomaly so strange it defies typical
containment classification and it Bears
a level 5 security lock meaning only
those on the level of the legendary o5
Council are cleared to even know about
it its greatest containment procedure is
the preservation of the very idea that
scp-3930 does not exist because the
alternative has terrifying implications
for all involved
scp-3930 is a one kilometer area in
Russia that is filled with non-existence
to even call it a white void would be
inaccurate because it implies the
existence of the color white and the
existence of the concept of a void
nothing exists with an scp-3930 and
anyone who directly observes 3930 runs
the risk of actively increasing its
power that's why special containment
features dictate that anyone who
observes 3930 must be forced to walk
into it afterwards which results in them
ceasing to exist they're destroyed on
the deepest level that anything can be
destroyed the very idea of them ceases
to be another reason that scp-3930 is so
special is that because it's the largest
area of nothing in existence interacting
directly with our reality it's the only
place that a huge number of patterned
screamers can be directly observed by
humans they're described as being like
sentient hallucinations one researcher
suggests that these pattern screamers
are created by the way the psyche
shatters when brought into contact with
raw true nothingness the nothingness
acts like a hateful mirror to our worst
thoughts reflecting them back at us in
the forms of restless screamers
regardless of what they actually are one
thing is for sure coming into direct
contact with one of these screamers is a
harrowing experience in the end it just
goes to show that pattern screamers are
a complex entity they can range from
microscopic to massive from pitiful to
downright terrifying and the sad result
is that in either case nothing can
really be done to stop them it's just as
impossible to stop the nothingness
existing in scp-3930 as it is to save
the entity trapped in the white spaces
of
scp-000 maybe the best option is to
actually be more like technical director
Rosen keep your head down Focus instead
on your own Petty worries and bask in
the warm Bliss that can only come with
having no idea what you're dealing with
the one downside is that this may make
you a pretty lousy it guy there are some
things human beings aren't meant to know
and it's the sworn duty of the SCP
Foundation to discover and contain such
information but sometimes knowledge is
discovered that shakes even the
foundation itself to its very core one
such Discovery occurred on April 28 2016
that night
scp-2935 made itself known to the
foundation Personnel to this day the
exact nature of scp-2935 is a mystery
that even the foundation's brightest
Minds can't completely understand
everything we know about
scp-2935 today comes from three doomed
missions to the anomalous Zone's
interior this is the story of those
Infamous Expeditions the nightmare began
around 5am when SCP Foundation site 81
in Bloomingdale Indiana intercepted the
distorted radio signal Communications
Personnel at the site traced this
strange signal back to the
unincorporated area of Joppa Indiana
near U.S Interstate 70. as is foundation
policy a team of field agents were
dispatched to the location in order to
determine what they were dealing with
however rather than finding anything
that could logically produce such a
signal they instead discovered a long
abandoned Cemetery the most recent death
on any of the Tombstones was recorded as
being over a hundred years ago although
way back in 1908 on further
investigation the foundation discovered
an unmapped Limestone Cave opening
beneath the cemetery and when they sent
a drone into the depths of the cave it
appeared to quickly exit out the other
side of the cave but something wasn't
right the area that the Drone was
observing appeared consistent with the
landscape from which it entered but now
it looked somehow grayer it lacked the
color of life of the place it just come
from the grass was dead there were no
trees no shrubs no animals or birds in
the sky they weren't looking at our
world they were looking at a strange
reflection of our world on the other
side of the cave in fact it wasn't a
cave at all it was a passageway between
two Dimensions it was
scp-2935 just then they were able to
unscramble the distorted transmission
they'd been receiving it went as follows
this is an automated emergency broadcast
from the SCP Foundation and to national
government one or more of our sites is
experiencing a communication breakdown
likely due to a containment breach of
unknown magnitude all citizens are
ordered to stay in their homes as
containment teams work to secure the
breach this message will broadcast from
April 20th 2016 until at that point the
message would cut and repeat as it had
for eight straight days the message
Source site 81 but not this site 81 the
SCP Foundation was receiving an
emergency distress signal from
themselves in another dimension a
bizarre event that even the foundation
had never experienced before field
agents were terrified by the
implications of what they just heard and
contacted site 81 commands to request
additional units the foundation wished
to fully understand this anomaly as
quickly as possible due to the Potential
Threat it could pose toward the
foundation so they dispatched mobile
task force Epsilon 13 codenamed Manifest
Destiny to perform the first of three
manned missions Into the Heart of the
anomalous Zone the first exploratory
mission in the scp-2935 was codenamed
Gauntlet and consisted of a four-man
team fitted with full hazmat suits and
direct video and audio links to Mission
command the team was led by a field
operative known only as agent Juno his
subordinates or agents kale Devlin and
Underwood their directive was to gather
samples and Survey the area positioned
directly around the insertion point
meaning the other cave mouth of scp-2935
the mission only lasted about an hour
but what they saw in there would stay
with these men for the rest of their
lives after a 15-minute Trek through the
cave Manifest Destiny arrived in the
mirror Dimension where they were struck
by the Eerie Silence of a place that
seemed identical and yet so different
from their home Dimension the first
observation they made was the total
absence of all living vegetation trees
grass weeds everything it was all dead
on orders from their superiors back in
the original Dimension that we'll refer
to from here on as Dimension Prime
Manifest Destiny headed deeper into the
mirror dimension of scp-2935 they travel
two kilometers without detecting a
single sign of plant or animal life not
even insects eventually They Came Upon a
farmhouse with two cars parked outside
with authorization from command Manifest
Destiny breached the house and headed in
side agent kale confirmed that there was
still power flowing to the building as
the lighting appeared to work just fine
but They Came Upon A horrifying
Discovery in The house's dining room
three adult corpses two female one male
were seated at the table a fourth corpse
that of a male child was sprawled out on
the ground nearby as if the death of
what looked to be an entire family
wasn't awful enough the Manifest Destiny
team noticed a number of other alarming
details there were no signs of
decomposition on the bodies nor did
there appear to be any obvious cause of
death the Family's last meal was still
on the table chicken mashed potatoes and
green beans while the food looked cold
and stale there was no evidence of rot
or spoiling the team founded open
newspaper dated April 19 2016
illustrating that the family may have
died a full eight days before the
discovery in dimension Prime Decay would
already be very well underway by that
point yet here there wasn't even a smell
instead everything was just covered in a
thin layer of dust command requested
that Manifest Destiny collects samples
of the food as well as Hair Skin and
fluids from the Corp for further study
small electronics like smartphones were
also taken from the bodies agent Devin
turned on the television in the living
room and found that while most stations
were now running test signals the
shopping channel was still live well the
feed was live at least both hosts sat in
front of the cameras dead but perfectly
preserved the date on the screen read
April 28 2016 suggesting that the times
of Dimension Prime and mirror Dimension
were exactly the same in fact everything
seemed the same the only difference
between the two Dimensions being that
some kind of mysterious apocalyptic
event had occurred in the last eight
days in scp-2935's Mirror Dimension but
exactly what had happened or how
remained a mystery when Manifest Destiny
exited the Farmhouse they once again
remarked on the lack of all signs of
life around them at this point the team
returned to the insertion point of
scp-2935 but were instructed to remain
in the mirror Dimension while additional
units joined them inside Manifest
Destiny swelled the 16 members with the
notable edition of agent Roy as the new
commanding field office the team split
into two groups of eight and agent Roy
and his men infiltrated the mirror
Dimension site-81 while agent Juno's
Detachment attempted to access the basis
off-site deep storage servers this
second expedition was codenamed Overland
and led the foundation's field agents
even deeper into the terrifying mystery
of scp-2935 accessing the site was easy
for Roy's Detachment it seemed there
were relatively few cars on the road at
the time of the mysterious Extinction
event in the distance fire still
smoldered and the wreckage of planes
that looked to have just dropped out of
the sky agent Roy and his team like all
SCP Foundation Personnel were fitted
with vitals trackers and they assumed
that the distress signal that started
this whole thing could have been
triggered by the deaths of every member
of the foundation at Once In The Mirror
Universe once inside site 81 they
realized that the Assumption was
probably right going door to door in the
administrative Wing they found the
perfectly preserved corpses of everyone
they knew to be stationed there in
dimension Prime people who were without
a doubt still alive in their Universe
sample from the corpses that the
foundation would later study even
confirmed the reason that the bodies
were perfectly preserved the corpses had
experienced complete and sudden death on
a cellular level and even the bacteria
that would typically take part in a
decomposition process had died with it
and scp-2935 death was total and
absolute across all types of life forms
as agent Roy's team ventured further
into the bowels of site-81 they made
another unsettling Discovery their own
corpses in roughly the same spots they'd
been inside Dimension Prime site 81 8
days prior some of the foundation's top
scientists including the esteemed Dr
bright were also found dead inside the
facility in an attempt to see just how
far this unexplained phenomenon
stretched agent Roy's team decided to
inspect the containment cells where they
found that all the mirror universes scps
including scp-2996 were dead in his
desperation to find some kind of
exception to the extinction event agent
Roy revealed a terrifying secret to the
rest of his team scp-682 the immortal
misanthropic lizard and one of the
deadliest creatures known to the SCP
Foundation was contained at this very
facility right below them could it have
something to do with what was going on
here they descended into the containment
facility to discover an even more
unsettling truth scp-682 the unkillable
anomaly floated dead in its tank death
truly made no exceptions within scp-2935
agent Roy's team left the site in rendez
food with agent Juno's team to send
their research back to Dimension prime
using automated drones both teams
remained in the mirror dimension for
another manned operation codenamed 19.
they had no idea it would be their final
mission as they descended deeper into
the facility passing more dead scps they
discovered one final clue based on the
activity of the foundation servers the
event occurred at roughly 3 A.M while
underground in scp-2935 site-81 the team
accidentally activated the bases on-site
nuclear weapon a Fail-Safe meant to be
detonated in the case of an emergency
Containment Breach due to the Bay basis
Fail-Safe protocols every member of the
Manifest Destiny team was locked and
sealed inside site-81 they along with
everything else were incinerated in the
nuclear blast once again the Mirror
Universe inside of scp-2935 was lifeless
but that isn't where it ends when the
automated drones returned out of the
scp-2935 cave to the field operations in
dimension Prime they were in for their
own horrifying Discovery none of the
footage or information gathered from
scp-2935 illuminated how or why the
extinction event occurred everyone and
everything simply dropped dead at the
exact same moment nobody was aware
nobody was prepared death came suddenly
and silently and none were spared all
the foundation on Dimension Prime were
left with was a message from one of the
agents from Manifest Destiny agent
Keller his final message was I don't
have any answers I don't think there are
any I'll do this one thing and hope that
fixes it seal it shut you've got to lock
it in here with us I'm sorry the
foundation were at first confused by
this until they discover covered a final
encrypted audio log buried in the files
recovered from the mirror universe's
site 81 it was a message from Keller
himself but not the Keller from Universe
Prime in this message Keller described
the foundation in the Mirror Universe
receiving the exact same distorted
transmission that they did a few days
earlier from a cave in Joppa when he and
the others were dispatched inside they
discovered the same lifeless
post-extinction event world that was now
so familiar to the foundation command
but there was a key difference this
wasn't the mirror Dimension they'd just
been studying but a third entirely
different dimension in his haunting
final words mirror Dimension Keller
admits that whatever caused the event in
that third dimension an entity in that
mirror Dimension Keller believed this
was the Specter of death itself and had
followed him back into his world and
history have repeated itself
scp-2935 was the passageway through
which absolute death could pass from
Dimension to Dimension and our Dimension
was the next in line the deaths of
manifest destiny may have saved our
entire universe as anyone passing back
through the cave had the potential to
bring death itself back with them the
foundation decided in the end to follow
Keller's advice they sealed the entrance
to scp-2935 with concrete and now kept
it under constant watch since what Waits
behind the barrier is an entity even
they have no power to stop if it ever
got through after all it had killed them
all before or at least another version
of them what's one more dimension on the
pile why it may now just seem like a
simple slab of concrete under an
abandoned Cemetery this is why scp-2935
might be the most dangerous SCP of all a
veteran worker of the SCP Foundation
sits at his terminal performing one of
the most critical tasks in the entire
organization creating a file for an as
yet undescribed SCP but there's
something terribly wrong his eyes are
glazed over his mouth hangs open is this
a zombie or a trained Foundation
researcher
what is going on like any large
International Organization it takes more
than just the exciting action-filled
jobs to keep the wheels turning at the
SCP Foundation sure the head researchers
guards mobile task force soldiers and
members of the o5 command get all the
praise but a legion of number crunchers
cleaners and paper pushers are equally
important one such person was archivist
Walter Bainbridge who had been tasked
with digitizing some of the older
records that the foundation had on file
it was when he was innocently recording
the details on
scp-050-060 that he first came under the
strange and startling effects of
scp-055 but the most peculiar part as
with all incidents of
scp-055's anomalous effects taking hold
is that Walter had no idea any of it was
happening in this new digitized filing
system he first took note of scp-053
Euclid class also known as the young
girl this anomaly was a seemingly normal
human female child who provoked
homicidal Insanity in those directly
exposed to her then scp-054 safe class
a non-aggressive humanoid female made
entirely of as well as biologically and
chemically identical to regular Spring
Water next
scp-056 Euclid Class A being that
changes form to suit its environment but
only when all observers lose focus of it
and then
scp-057 safe class an underground
chamber that crushes the humans who walk
Within it was at this point that Walter
received a concerned message from one of
his superiors at site 19 Mr Kovach the
message praised the thorough
digitization of the other anomaly's
records but was confused about why
Walter had left out any mention of
scp-055 immediately Walter was
embarrassed how could he have forgotten
scp-055 that iconic anomaly known for
well he couldn't quite say off the top
of his head but he'd be sure to look
into it a quick trip to the site-19
archive showed him that there was
actually quite a hefty file on the
nature of
scp-055 which must have been the result
of a huge number of studies what struck
him as strange was that all the files
were filled out in pen rather than being
typed up like a traditional file the
majority of these nodes were written in
shorthand too as though they were
frantically taken during the tests
themselves on extremely short notice
there weren't even any redactions Walter
made a mental note of what he had seen
put the file back in its proper place
and headed back to his computer terminal
however after riding in an almost
trance-like stay he looked back on his
work to see that he had written an entry
on
scp-058 a giant evil bovine heart with
insect legs and a scorpion Stinger
strange he thought that's when Walter
got a call from Mr Kovach on his
foundation issue phone and he didn't
sound happy he'd given Walter direct
instructions to go back and digitize the
files on zero five five and instead he'd
been working on zero five a what was the
meaning of This Walter was typically an
extremely loyal and diligent employee
but the verbal barrage from his
supervisor had him considering talking
back just this once and hoping it didn't
get him demoted to d-class and thrown
into 682's Acid Bath for playtime Walter
Galt picked up some courage and
interrupted Mr kovach's rant to ask if
he had any idea what scp-055 actually
was the line went silent for a moment
then his supervisor spoke again this
time with less confidence of course I
can tell you about
scp-055 it's a classic one of the first
hundred how could you forget it's uh or
yeah you know it's I think it's the one
with um
another long pause as Mr Kovach seemed
to search for the words but instead just
trailed off into silence knowing that
some of the anomalies on file were
dangerous mimetic hazards Walter was
worried for a moment that he may have
accidentally killed his boss by getting
him to think too hard about
scp-055 he asked if Mr Kovach was okay
and finally got a reply
I'm sorry I seem to have zoned out for a
second there what were we talking about
again
but this time it was Walter who couldn't
answer he had no idea at all what the
two of them were discussing just moments
ago he felt disoriented and kind of sick
like they'd taken some low level
amnestics Mr Kovach told Walter to get
back to his filing duties and they'd
speak later Walter then checked the
messages he'd received from Mr Kovach
earlier and there it was plain as day
you missed zero five five go back and
digitize that before proceeding Mr K but
Walter had never even heard of an
scp-055 if such an anomaly even existed
what was going on here in that moment
Walter realized he was dealing with
something much Stranger Than Just a
standard digitization job after all how
could he properly complete his duties of
scp-055 seemed to be impossible to speak
right or even think about unless you
were directly observing it at that
moment Walter had to know and ask around
the entirety of site 19 to find the
answers if he had to
sadly for Walter he was about to embark
on a much more challenging task than he
could have ever imagined to paraphrase a
supposed quote from Socrates all I know
is that I know nothing and that's also
about the extent of the knowledge we
have on
scp-055 also known as the anti-mean and
the self-keeping secret what does it
look like when and how was it obtained
by the foundation what are its anomalous
abilities the this thing dangerous we
may never know because the only
anomalous ability of scp-055 that we're
aware of is the fact that nobody is
capable of retaining any information
about it it's crucial to note that
whatever zero five five is it isn't
invisible or Indescribable Foundation
Personnel are perfectly capable of
entering its containment chamber and
observing it without incident but mere
minutes after leaving the chamber any
memories of the particulars of 055 seem
to spontaneously erase themselves
hence the self-keeping secret but this
didn't deter Walter perhaps his greatest
Advantage was that he didn't know enough
about the thing he was investigating to
know how futile his mission was he
wanted to know the unknowable and a
pesky issue like impossibility wouldn't
stop him he'd get to whoever he needed
to at site 19 to get the answers he
needed of course most people had no
knowledge of the mysterious anomaly the
common response he got back from his
colleagues was zero five five do we even
have a zero five five well the
realization of sudden memory loss or the
realization of 055's existence has been
known to cause momentary stress there
are no known long-term physical or
mental effects from zero five five's
anomalous abilities it's a fleeting idea
in its purest form like forgetting why
you walked into a room 055 could be the
most harmless object on the foundation's
roster or the most deadly either way we
just don't know at times Walter worried
he was going insane zero five five and
everything related to it was gaslighting
him with zero five five even real the
one thing that proved to him that zero
five five must have existed is that its
containment chamber existed
according to the official records kept
by the foundation on the site-19
containment facilities
zero five five is kept in a five by five
by 2.5 meter Square Room constructed a
50-foot thick cement with a faraday cage
surrounding the cement walls the report
continues that access is via a heavy
containment door measuring 2 by 2.5
meters constructed on bearings to ensure
door closes and locks automatically
unless held open deliberately
zero five five cell is one of the few to
have no posted security guards and any
Personnel working on other scps in the
area are ordered to remain at least 50
feet from the geometric Center of zero
five five cell
where the anomaly itself is capped when
he tried to explore further why the cell
was constructed in this manner he found
that surprise surprise nobody knew
055 was an anomaly whose containment
requirements were so mysterious that it
automatically netted itself a ketter
class designation after all how can you
properly contain something you can't
even hope to comprehend there were
plenty of rumors about the true nature
of 055
some of the more conspiratorial Minds at
site 19 theorized that 055 was actually
an autonomous or remotely controlled spy
inserted into the site to observe
Foundation operations or even Humanity
as a whole if you're on the more
paranoid end of the psychological
Spectrum this Theory makes total sense
an anomaly that's physically impossible
to remember even when writings and
pictures on the subject exist would be a
perfect spy however this was all
ultimately little more than speculation
Walter was barely any further along than
when he started there were multiple
points in his investigations where
Walter seriously considered giving up
until finally he had a major
breakthrough Dr Bartholomew Hughes and
Dr John marichek were two scientists
that had performed extensive research
into zero five five and who Walter hoped
might have the answers he sought about
the self-keeping secret these scientists
were the first to discover the
anti-memetic nature of 0.055 performing
numerous tests on d-class Personnel to
see if it was possible to create
feasible written records sketches or any
other records or Impressions that could
bypass its anomalous effects the
disorienting memory ruining effects of
055 also extend to any materials
concerning 055 it seems to be a truly
uncrackable code but Dr Hughes may have
finally found some cracks in the armor
for starters the fact that we're able to
remember that 055 is an anti-memetic is
an ironic exception to its anti-memetic
qualities this Revelation also inspired
another realization from Dr Hughes
would it be possible to discover more
about zero five five from the process of
deduction rather than the typical
induction in other words could they
possibly learn about zero five five by
figuring out all the things it isn't
rather than what it is Dr marichek
designed an experiment with Dr Hughes to
explore this Theory they designed the
experiment around a simple question is
055 not spherical in designing the
question to specifically find out what
055 isn't they hope to subvert the
anomaly's anti-memetic powers Walter was
fascinated by this potential method of
getting answers marichek and Hughes
found that while the questioning process
for those exposed was often arduous and
frustrating
they could now definitely say that 055
is not a sphere it is theoretically
possible to discover the true nature of
055 by an almost endless barrage of
deductive questions though whether
command would authorize the resources
for such extensive testing is still an
open question Walter and his desperation
begged marichek and Hughes for clearance
to view zero five five himself the
Curiosity had become too great during a
search to just walk away with the single
fact that 055 was in spherical he needed
to see this thing and after several
weeks of filling out forms and cutting
red tape his wish was finally granted
Walter Bainbridge was allowed a private
audience with
scp-055 the subject of his month's long
Obsession Outsiders observe that Walter
spent just over an hour in the
containment chamber taking photos
drawing sketches writing down notes
recording audio logs and reciting memory
mnemonics he was pulling out every stop
to counteract the anti-memetic effects
of the self-keeping secret he was
adamant that he would not be defeated by
his non-spherical Nemesis not after all
this time and effort once his time in
the 055 containment chamber was over he
retired back to his office to finally
digitize his exhaustive findings so that
his supervisor Mr Kovach would finally
get off his back Walter smiled to deep
breath and began to type
scp-059 ketter class this anomaly is a
radioactive mineral that emits a unique
radiation known as Delta radiation
exposure to this radiation has caused
strange fungal growth on the infected
wait what was this supposed to be about
again oh well it couldn't have been that
important it was November 20th 2019 and
the helicopter circled far above in the
freezing wind of the Antarctic SCP
Foundation site director Jason Monroe
looked down at the isolated above ground
facilities of provisional site 344-1
something about this place made him
nervous edgy and for good reason between
2003 and 2019 29 mobile task force units
and 73 members of d-class personnel had
gone missing here and never been found
Monroe thought he was here for a routine
investigation into negligence and
mismanagement but little did he know he
was in for so much more this is the
story of
scp-5545 and one man's journey into his
own worst nightmare literally but this
nightmare began a long time ago 300
years to be exact and like most
nightmares it started as a dream that
dream was one of expansion National
Powers across Europe wanted to be the
first to conquer the globe and expand
into new territories and sent countless
exploratory missions off into the
unknown to achieve this goal any history
book will tell you that the first
Outsiders to lay eyes upon the continent
of Antarctica did so in 1820 the reality
is that the first ones to get there
actually landed in the late 1700s the
hapless explorers ventured into Mainland
Antarctica and made base camps before
searching and digging for any useful
resources nearby They Came Upon a
strange Discovery a hallway hidden
beneath the ice not a passage in the ice
but a true hallway complete with light
fixtures the confused explorers ventured
down into these impossible hallways and
for many of them it would be the last
thing they ever did no matter how long
they walked it seemed like the hallways
just kept going as they continued to
walk for hours they hoped to find
something anything and eventually they
did they pass from these hallways into
somewhere different altogether and most
of them were never heard from again
those who did manage to escape often
died or took their own lives soon after
whatever it was they discovered down
there they didn't want to live with it
on their minds it's believed that over
70 Colonial explorers disappeared or
died this way and that most who found
these endless hallways beneath the
Antarctic Ice never returned the
multiple anomalous objects and phenomena
that make up
scp-5545 came into the foundation's
hands several centuries later on
September 18 2003 when during an
expedition into the Antarctica they too
found the endless hallways the
foundation-built provisional site 344-1
around them hoping to safely seal them
off from any other unwitting Antarctic
explorers or researchers but there was
something else lurking beneath the ice
in Antarctica something dangerous the
hallways were designated as
scp-5545-1 and were thought to be the
extent of the anomalous activity at the
site but soon as CP
5545-2 was discovered which resulted in
the deaths of 16 researchers so what
exactly is
5545-2 it's an entity so volatile that
even knowing about it is considered to
be a Containment Breach and as a result
it's kept in provisional side
344-2 unlike site 344-1
344-2 isn't a physical space it's
conceptual accessible only through the
endless hallways created with the
express purpose of keeping 5545-1 and 50
545-2 separate why because whenever the
two come into contact the result is
5545-3 the network of endless hallways
expanding if they remained in contact
the hallways would continue to expand
and the entire planet could be filled
with endless hallways in just four to
six hours while the two are apart though
5545-3 reverses but it always would take
just a few hours to throw the whole
world into a chaos of infinite hallways
scp-5545 has been given the
classification safe wait we're dealing
with a mysterious and volatile anomaly
that claimed a huge number of lives and
still somehow eludes True Foundation
understanding yet the official SCP
Foundation classification is safe how
could speed Monroe was the director of
site 58 and was the definition of
no-nonsense prior to taking the site
director position he was a decorated
member of mobile task force Ada 10 and
helped contain numerous ketter class
anomalies he'd been around the
proverbial block when it came to
anomalous activity and something about
scp-5545 and the management of
provisional site 344 seemed awfully
suspicious to him and he had questions
like how such an unpredictable anomaly
could be declared safe and why had there
been such a lapse of communication
between the foundation and Dr Gabriel
Reed who'd been running the facility for
the past two decades and most of all
just what exactly was the mysterious
scp-5545-2 Monroe started to believe
that something terrible had happened at
the site and Reed was covering it all up
but to find out for sure we'd need to go
to Antarctica and investigated himself
information about this supposedly safe
anomaly was highly class
those without o5 clearance could face
termination for snooping but that didn't
scare Jason Monroe he dealt with Cutters
before he could deal with this or so he
thought Monroe submitted a request and
was granted unanimous approval by the o5
council to travel to provisional site
344 and get to the bottom of this
mystery he took a chopper to the base
soon after armed with a concealed
firearm and a hostile meme detector or
hmd to test whether the base and its
staff had somehow Fallen under a
hazardous memetic effect from
scp-5545 he'd find the answers or die
trying the moment Monroe arrived he
couldn't help but notice the strange way
the staff behaved they seemed listless
almost oppressive when he showed his
credentials to a researcher they simply
said
scp-5545-2 is contained in site 344-2
his request to see Dr Reed that night
was denied Dr Reed was busy he was told
wait until tomorrow the next day a Dr
Monroe met with Dr Reed but the results
of the meeting were underwhelming to say
the least just like the rest of the
staff on the site he seemed exhausted as
though he hadn't slept in days his
responses were quiet and evasive and he
refused to tell Monroe anything that
wasn't in the official files already
Monroe ran the conversation through the
hmd and found nothing out of the
ordinary what was going on here Monroe
was irritated but not deterred nothing
would stop him from finding out the
truth
the next day he flexed his o5
credentials and hacked into the base's
security system this gave him access to
cameras around site 344-1 but more
importantly there was a single camera
inside the mysterious
sci-344-2 jackpot but when he looked at
it the feed was an entirely black screen
with the words
scp-5545-2 is contained in site
344-2 the footage of the staff in 344-1
was equally strange the 18 employees on
site all sat at computer banks with
nothing but static playing on their
screens Monroe kept digging though and
was able to hack into the security
footage of Dr Reed's office as he
watched he discovered a 15-minute period
where Reed left the office each day he
could use this brief window to break in
and collect more Intel on
scp-5545-2 Monroe was so wrapped up in
the investigation that he almost forgot
the more immediate danger around around
him and nearly wandered into one of the
Endless hallways of 5545-1 by mistake he
made a note to be more careful in the
future his first attempt at breaking
into Dr Reed's office didn't produce
many answers one piece of evidence was a
blurry picture of what looked like a
mobile task force entering a 55-45-1
hallway in the dark another was a
spreadsheet featuring all the Personnel
living or dead who worked at the site
but one name and the details of whether
this person was alive or dead was
completely redacted anything
particularly juicy was hidden behind o5
clearance if Monroe wanted the answers
he needed to break through that night he
had a horrific reoccurring nightmare one
that had plagued him since he joined MTF
at a 10 he dreamed that he was in a
fancy dining room with a grand fireplace
the room was full of statues of men and
women the men looked angry and the woman
looked afraid as he approached the
fireplace the ceiling extended
infinitely up into the darkness suddenly
the zombie-like body of a teenage girl
appears in the fireplace hanging from a
long thread her eyes look Furious and
full of rage and Monroe somehow knows
that he's the reason for her hate when
he steps into the fireplace in the
Stream she attacks him the two
intertwined and they burn forever the
one difference was that in this new
iteration of the dream he blinked upon
entering the fireplace and suddenly he
was in the hallway he woke sure that
something was terribly wrong here but he
couldn't give up now the next day Dr
Monroe broke into Reed's office and made
a horrifying Discovery he found files
indicating that to read was knowingly
sending mobile task forces and d-class
Personnel into the infinite hallways of
5545-1 to their Doom he also found
evidence that Reed and the researchers
had been spying on him somehow
intercepting copies of the notes he had
been taking that's when Dr Reed entered
the office and interrupted him Monroe
panicked and Drew his weapon holding the
doctor at gunpoint he was breaking so
many Foundation rules but right now he
feared for his life the doctor seemed
unbothered by Monroe's threats though he
told Monroe that everything was going to
plan and that he should go back to his
room Monroe was becoming increasingly
paranoid he felt that at any moment
guards my first in and execute him
nothing about this place made sense he
worried he was going insane perhaps the
only way to find answers was to go even
deeper to risk it all and Venture
through the endless hallways to find
scp-5545-2 himself and finally discover
what the thing actually was Monroe left
his room and stepped into one of the
Endless hallways of 5545-1 that was
located just across from his dorm he
found that it was a hallway like all the
others on site playing concrete one of
age with simple light fixtures on the
walls he walked for hours recording with
a concealed device the light suddenly
went out leaving him in complete
darkness when they flicked back on he
was in a very different environment a
grand old carpeted hallway the kind
you'd see in an old mansion he broke
into a cold sweat what was so familiar
about this place
walking racked with Terror until this
new hallway finally led him to the place
he'd been seeking site
344-2 the domain of
5545-2 it was a large poorly lit room
filled with grimacing statues and a
large fireplace at the far end it was
the exact same room from Monroe's dream
with one horrifying difference Monroe
noticed a single white thread hanging
down from the infinite ceiling and when
he looked up to find its source he
screamed there were hundreds of bodies
hanging and swinging from the ceiling
above him everyone who
scp-5545-2 had ever killed including MTF
members d-class personnel and even the
colonial explorers from hundreds of
years before and all of them were him
every single one they had his face and
there hanging in the middle of the room
at ground level was the body of a
teenage girl the one from his dream that
moment he finally recognized her she was
the girl he killed the first hymn
hundreds of years ago much like Monroe
you're probably wondering what is going
on here thanks to Declassified
communication between Dr Reed and the o5
council we can tell you Jason Monroe was
a man who's been reincarnated hundreds
of times over the last 300 years ever
since he murdered a teenage girl a girl
named Emily his daughter this murder
sparked the existence of
scp-5545 as an eternally reoccurring
punishment for his crimes since figuring
this out the foundation has kept tabs on
Monroe's reincarnations whether they're
MTF members d-class Personnel or even
site directors they see to it that these
reincarnations always find their way
back to
5545-2 to take his punishment and
prevent the infinite hallway expansion
that threatens to destroy the world it's
a plan everyone is in on everyone except
but every time he enters that nightmare
hunting room it all comes rushing back
in that moment though he knew his crying
and he somehow knew how many times this
punishment had unfolded for him he now
had two choices repent and accept the
punishment again or leave and activate
55 45-3 potentially allowing the endless
tunnels to expand across the world like
his many predecessors Monroe made the
decent Choice he accepted his punishment
and allowed his own string to coil
around him as the lights in the room
went off one by one leaving only
Darkness Jason Monroe that version of
him at least was never seen again but
the SCP Foundation is already eyeing up
his next reincarnation and preparing to
let this Twisted cycle play out all over
again it's skitters in the dark it's
insect-like legs tapping across the
marble floors as terrified Foundation
researchers flee they hear its voice
the Deep silky tones of an elderly
British man spouting nonsense like the
nightmare is a dream to the nameless
slug that wanders across Minefield and
the remains of dear and Kings while the
scientists run the creature gains on
them it's fast impossibly fast while
they still try to escape down this
darkened hallway ear-splitting
Containment Breach Sirens blast through
the air they may try to escape but it's
futile in a sense they're already dead
all they are now is prey for the heart
of darkness when someone says the word
heart there are a lot of images that
come to mind you might think of
Valentine's Day heart-shaped cards and
candies you might think of heartbreak
rejection loss you might simply think of
a heart in the anatomical sense the
vital organ that pumps blood through our
bodies it's unlikely though that you
would associate the word heart with
Terror destruction and countless deaths
however employees of the SCP Foundation
might think differently especially if
they've ever had a run-in with
scp-058 much of the information about
058's Discovery is highly classified but
the few details that are known paint a
chilling picture at an SCP Foundation
test site the day was proceeding as
usual with scientists and security
Personnel going about their regular
daily tasks there was no hint of danger
in the air beyond the base level that
always comes with setting foot in an SCP
Foundation site at least several
researchers were performing an
experiment the specifics of which have
been expunged from all records involving
the carcass of a cow when a researcher
Dr C placed his hands on the specimen
and prepared to dissect it he was
shocked to feel a pulse coming from the
supposedly dead animal Dr C shared his
surprise with his colleagues but his
concerns were dismissed immediately
clearly this was a corpse he was
imagining things they said after all he
was relatively new to the job it was
probably just nerves the head researcher
Dr Al insisted that he take over pushing
Dr C to the side Dr Al began to make an
incision into the animal's chest as he
did he too felt something peculiar there
was no doubt about it this dead cow had
a beating heart he looked up from his
work to tell the other researchers to
explain what he felt but by then it was
too late something horrible was already
happening with a stomach churning sound
of squishing flesh the cow's heart burst
from its chest and flopped onto the
floor it was terrifyingly large and all
the doctors jump back from the side of
it four spindly spider-like legs poked
through the Flesh of the heart and it
began to quickly skitter about the room
researchers reviewing the security
footage would later note that it didn't
just move randomly it seemed agitated
angry at being discovered and it
displayed immediate hostility towards
the scientists in the room four
tentacles next unfurled from within the
heart and stretched out into full
writhing appendages they move
frighteningly fast as the heart whipped
around the room and were coated in sharp
spines finally a stinger poked out from
the back of the heart where the whole of
the superior vena cava should be all the
scientists leapt into action with one
reaching for a scalpel and another
moving towards the door but before the
men could so much as call for help the
tentacles wrapped around them and ripped
them to shreds hearing screams coming
from the laboratory security Personnel
arrived to contain the threat however
there were no match for the strange
creature that would soon be known as
scp-058 it tore through the security
team in minutes leaving their tattered
remains in its wake much to the horror
of the surviving Personnel at the site
scp-058 was able to escape containment
and and make its way to a neighboring
Town reports of the incident said that
when the creature reached the town you
could hear the screaming for Miles
scp-05a carved a path of violence
through the town attacking everything in
sight with its stinger and tentacles and
leaving a trail of strange fluid from
its stinger dozens of citizens were
killed and seventy percent of the
buildings were completely destroyed when
agents were dispatched to the location
to retrieve the creature they were
shocked to see the level of Destruction
caused by something so small the scent
of blood and smoke filled the air and
severed limbs littered the ground
alongside splintered wood and collapsed
brick the survivors removed from the
wreckage were inconsolable only coming
down once they were given an amnesic to
erase their memory of the encounter with
scp-058 they had to be given new lives
as well as there was nothing left of
their old ones SCP Foundation agents
were only able to capture and contain s
cp058 after it was crushed by pieces of
a building that collapsed on top of it
they found it flattened under a slab of
stone legs flailing uselessly tentacles
lymph the agents were able to safely
remove the debris and bring in the heart
without any more casualties that day
once it was brought into captivity the
heart was contained for three weeks and
remained largely quiet during that time
it was almost inconceivable that this
small creature hadn't been killed in the
incident but the foundation would soon
learn that this creature was freakishly
durable it escaped once more while being
transferred to an SCP Containment site
again causing injuries and death having
only experienced scp-058 in its docile
injured form the team responsible for
the transfer was unprepared for the
sheer power and violence the creature
was capable of it was able to escape an
armored car and make its way into a
forest where it eviscerated several
squirrels and rabbits it's or rather
they were believed to be squirrels and
rabbits the remains were too mutilated
to properly identify it was only finally
apprehended after being crushed by an
armored tank but even this didn't kill
the creature and it was transferred to
Armed biocontainment Area 14 where it
remains to this day there was a great
deal about scp-058 that is horrifying
but there is one attribute it has shown
in captivity that would make even the
most seasoned researchers skin crawl
though it has no anatomical capacity for
speech no throat vocal cords or even a
respiratory system as cp058 speaks not
only does it speak but it speaks
constantly in the deep voice of an
elderly British man no one knows who the
voice might belong to or if it belongs
to anyone at all perhaps it belongs only
to scp-058 somehow as is often the case
with scps that are capable of speech
there have been multiple attempts to
interview the creature and each time it
ended in complete disaster the only
interview with an available transcript
interview05804 was conducted by Dr
Johnston with several Personnel in the
room for additional security Dr Johnston
attempted to get at the origins of the
creature asking for its name and where
it was from the creature responded in
cryptic unsettling poetry giving answers
to simple questions with
Aya dreams of the queen Wonders that
lived inside the hearts of love and
silent treatments for all the elderly
that I knew were one's whole after the
fourth recitation of a similar verse
from the heart Personnel d067 made a
comment on the creepy nature of its
responses almost as if it was offended
by the remark
scp-058 immediately stretched a tentacle
across the room wrapped it around d-067
and lifted him into the air he began
screaming and longing at the tentacle in
an attempt to free himself as his fellow
Personnel tried to help him they grabbed
at the tentacle but found their hands
pierced and bloodied by the spikes that
cover it Dr Johnston commanded 0-5-8 to
let him go but it did not oblige instead
the man was crushed to death by the
tentacle and his limp body left to drop
to the floor the interview concluded
with a single statement from the
nightmarish heart those sensual violence
of lust is all the Assurance you will
ever need to know the worth of life
scp-058 never seems to say anything that
has to do with the people or events
around it it speaks in the same haunting
poetic language even when it's attacking
or killing something no matter what
happens to it what is done to it or what
anyone says
scp-058 keeps talking and its tone of
voice with the pace of speech never
changing and further attempts to
interview it have been a due to the
safety risk involved so what happened to
the creature often called The Heart of
Darkness where is it now
scp-058 is kept in an isolated
containment chamber made of reinforced
heat resistant steel with a backing of
reinforced Concrete in order to placate
its bloodthirsty carnivorous Tendencies
the creature is given a live cow every
three days it is uncertain how exactly
scp-058 eats given that it does not have
a mouth or stomach but every time it is
finished with a cow only bones remain
routine maintenance is conducted on a
tight schedule and the heart is never
allowed out of its containment area
under any circumstances after two
previous escapes from containment the
foundation is not taking any chances its
constant speech is recorded via audio
devices that are running at all times
out of concern for their safety and
mental health no Personnel are permitted
to listen to recordings of scp-058
speaking for more 30 minutes at a time
it is unknown what will happen to
someone who listens for longer but it
has been suggested that the consequences
could be dire if the creature ever
escapes again the containment site is
ordered to be destroyed via the
detonation of an on-site nuclear weapon
under no circumstances can it be allowed
to make its way out into the world again
even with all these precautions in place
scp-058 has been responsible for over
150 deaths at its current containment
site there are some at the foundation
who have campaign for scp-058 to be
terminated believing that there is more
harm than good done by keeping it alive
however all attempts to terminated have
so far failed no matter how much
physical trauma the heart suffers it
does not seem to be able to be killed it
can only be incapacitated for a short
time there is a classic Horror Story by
Edgar Allan Poe called The Telltale
Heart in it a man murders an old man and
buries his body beneath the floor
floorboards of his home there even
though the old man is certainly dead the
murderer swears he can hear the beating
of the heart coming up through the
floorboards no matter what he does to
quiet the sound he cannot Escape it and
is eventually driven mad by the
incessant beating of the dead man's
heart
scp-058 may not be a man's heart a human
heart or even a real heart at all
however just like The Telltale Heart it
continues to impossibly beat no matter
how hard anyone tries to stop it the
steady thump of its pulse haunts the SCP
Foundation a grim reminder that there is
something within its walls that can and
will kill everyone it can if given the
chance it couldn't be destroyed by
collapsed buildings an armored tank or
an army of experts and the contingency
plan of a nuclear blast is not even
guaranteed to work it is entirely
possible that once the facility has been
laid waste and all the staff have been
incinerated and the smoke has finally
cleared the Heart of Darkness will still
be there still beating still talking and
still killing it all started in 1983
with reports of human trafficking in the
heart of Sin City the FBI had gotten
word of a potential trafficking ring
operating out of an abandoned department
store in Las Vegas Nevada and
immediately began organizing a secret
raid on the building while they would
indeed encounter something horrifying
within that abandoned department store
it wasn't criminals or human trafficking
in fact it wasn't human at all this is
the horrifying story of
scp-847 after weeks of planning the raid
on the department store was conducted in
the dead of night agents covered all the
exits and entrances and a helicopter was
stationed nearby in case anyone
attempted to run it should have been a
perfect trap but things never go as
planned when you don't know what you're
dealing
the agents breached the door and began
searching the darkened building it
didn't appear that there was any power
so the traffickers must have had great
night vision and a high tolerance for
creepy locales agents soon heard a faint
humming sound coming from below a
generator it must be located in the
basement and be the Hub of this criminal
Enterprise readying themselves for
whatever they were about to find the
agents descended into the basement as
they moved deeper into the building they
found that lighting rigs had been set up
they must be getting closer to something
but that something was still a mystery a
senior FBI special agent was leading the
charge his pistol drawn and ready it was
quiet too quiet did the traffickers
already realize they were coming in
clear out he was ready to consider this
bus to bust when he heard a quiet
muelling in the distance a persistent
whining whimper that was undeniably
human he gave the signal to his fellow
agents to follow the noise they
proceeded forward towards the pain
sounds and found themselves in a wide
well-lit room filled with department
store mannequins all were broken to some
degree some were totally smashed to
Pieces some were chained to walls and
locked in cages others were wrapped in
plastic the agent wondered whether this
was some kind of Twisted junk or a
messed up avant-garde art piece that's
when he noticed her a single Crouch
figure in the distance hunched over and
whimpering in a darkened corner of the
room near a full-length mirror he
couldn't fully make around but he got
the sense that something was wrong she
was injured bent over was she even
missing an arm just one of these
monsters done to this woman he whispered
a request for backup Into His Radio and
pushed on when he got within 50 meters
of this strange woman her demeanor
changed entirely she jerked around her
movements forced erratic and painful
looking the woman stared directly into
the agent's eyes and began hobbling
towards him occasionally stopping to
strike a pose as if modeling during a
photo shoot just then the agent made a
horrifying realization this thing moving
towards them wasn't a woman at all it
was a living mannequin as she got closer
though he realized that the mannequin's
broken left forearm had been carved into
a large shiv a female Junior FBI agent
had been one of the many to pour into
the room when the raid leader had
radioed for backup the second she
entered the 50 meter range of this
strange mannequin everything changed in
an instant its eyes and mouth began
dripping with a thick viscous resin its
whimpering gasp suddenly became vicious
ear splitting screeches and it turned
its gaze from the senior FBI agent who
was now focused on the junior agent who
had just entered the room and broke into
a terrifying run straight towards her
the mannequin moved with a violent
single-minded purpose other agents began
firing but it was running freakishly
fast and easily dodged most of the ball
bullets the few that actually hit seem
to do nothing to slow the creature down
it Shrugged off the damage and kept
running with a great leap it landed on
the terrified Junior agent and began
jabbing her with its bladed arm the
other agents stopped firing fearing they
might accidentally hit their colleague
during the Panic the mannequin was
ruthless clawing and stabbing with the
strange resin leaking out of its every
orifice terrified and unable to reach
her gun the agent remembered her
training she reached into her belt and
grabbed her stun gun jamming the two
probes up against the creature's chest
and giving it 30 000 volts the creature
spasm fell backwards and collapsed in
the Heap on the ground Frozen this was
the first recorded encounter with
scp-847 a violent living mannequin with
a serious problem with women this
terrifying report was passed up the
chain of command until it landed on the
desk of a foundation agent working in
the FBI the foundation quickly swooped
in and claimed the mannequin delivered
necessary amnesic treatment to all who'd
witnessed it and closely observed the
female Junior FBI agent's recovery in a
private hospital with Foundation ties as
it turns out they were right to do so as
the junior agent was in for a gruesome
fate while the wound she'd suffered at
the hands of scp-847 didn't appear fatal
the fact that the mannequin's anomalous
resin excretions entered the open wound
changed everything several hours after
being committed the junior agent began
complaining of Lynn's stiffness and
difficulty moving this quickly developed
into full paralysis over time her skin
and internal organs began to harden
until the process dubbed plastination
came to a gruesome end the junior agent
wasn't just dead she had been
transformed into a mannequin Foundation
researchers were met with a truly
horrifying realization this means that
all the other Broken Mannequins found
with scp-847 were likely won living
humans attacked and transformed by the
anomaly now a source for new harvested
body parts now safely interred at a
foundation containment facility though
the real tests on scp-847 to determine
its behavior and physical attributes
could begin the most important detail
about scp-847 is that its aggression is
exclusively directed towards women as
opposed to when it encounters men and
its instincts are more self-destructive
through a series of tests and
observations researchers have been able
to pin down three different distinct
patterns of behavior for
scp-847 pattern Z behaviors occur when
there are no humans standing within 50
meters of scp-847 the mannequin will
seek out a full-length mirror and pose
in front of it much like a department
store mannequin attempting to show off
its clothes it remains largely inanimate
during these periods and will very
occasionally use a finger or whatever
appendage is available given its habit
for self-mutilation to scratch messages
on nearby surfaces pattern y Behavior
occurs when male humans with XY
chromosomes enter a 50 meter radius
around
scp-847 just like its reaction to the
male FBI agents who founded 847 will
initially emit vocalizations that seem
like whimpering gasps before making eye
contact and striking provocative poses
while approaching the subject it will
then remain static and allow the male
subject to pose its body however after
the male subject leaves the area 847
will enter a state of considerable
distress and begin removing or
shattering parts of its body the
foundation has found that the parts
removed or shattered are often
consistent with parts that the male
subjects found displeasing during
interactions showing a masochistic
desire to impress these parts are then
harvested back from plastinated victims
which brings us to the most dangerous of
its Behavior patterns pattern X
behaviors occur when female humans enter
a 50 meter radius around the creature
847 will immediately become brutally
aggressive switching its noises from
whimpers to violent screeches and growls
847 experiences enhance physical
capabilities during pattern X Stakes its
speed has been measured at 45 kilometers
per hour making it as fast as the
legendary
scp-096 it's also been shown to exhibit
extreme physical strength it's during
this pattern of behavior that it begins
excreting its deadly resin which has
been proven to only be dangerous to
women in these states the only thing
capable of reliably pacifying the being
is a powerful electric shock the shock
causes the creatures resin to harden
temporarily incapacitating it for
roughly five minutes other Conventional
Weapons and damage has no meaningful
effect on
scp-847 after a number of incidents that
had sad in violent endings the
foundation Ethics Committee forbade the
use of female d-class personnel and
scp-847 testing when it came to female
subjects 847 always slipped into a state
of extreme aggression so instead the
foundation began testing with male
subjects in hopes of better
understanding the Dynamics between human
males and
scp-847 various misogynistic d-class
males were introduced into the
containment chamber which was modeled to
look like a bedroom for the purposes of
Behavioral study each one either during
or after their interaction with scp-847
was told to comment on some aspect they
felt dissatisfied with the mannequin
shattered its own chest after hearing it
described as being out of proportion
after another d-class called its nose
ugly the mannequin broke it off after
another said that its hair was out of
fashion and commented on its inability
to drink it tore out its hair and liver
all parts were replaced after the EXP
environments things took their most
violent and upsetting term yet with the
introduction of
d-7294 a lot of the time d-class
Personnel are considered to be as
Anonymous as they are expendable but
d-7294 is an exception before becoming
d-class he was a successful cello
teacher who brutally murdered one of his
teenage students and her mother he's
typically employed in tests when the
foundation wishes to see interactions
between anomalies and humans with
confirmed Psychopathic personalities
during his interaction with scp-847 he
belittled and humiliated the mannequin
he forced it into uncomfortable poses
and even snapped off one of its fingers
before being dragged from the room by
Foundation guards in the following
debrief he further berated the mannequin
as useless and lousy at its job of being
controlled by him in response 847
extracted its own brains eyes and
clavicle before shattering its own hands
in dismay so why does 847 behave this
way while it may appear monstrous it
seems that the reason scp-847 does what
it does is All Too Human it hurts women
because it itself is hurting and it's
willing to hurt itself even more for the
approval of the objects of its desire as
a result it's an anomaly trapped in an
endless cycle of pain and violence
perhaps one day it'll be able to free
itself from the loop but that day is
unlikely to come for this murderous
mannequin anytime soon London is the
second largest city in Europe and
underneath this bustling city is one of
the oldest and largest networks of train
tunnels in the world but that's not the
only huge old structure located beneath
the city of London below even the
deepest underground Metro stations of
this historic City there's a whole
artificial world of surveillance cyborgs
impossible architecture and stomach
churning nutritional supplements so so
be sure to mine the Gap because we're
about to take you on a tour of
scp-1678 also known as UNL London
scp-1678 is located one kilometer below
the city of London England from all
appearances it seems to be an exact copy
of the city though aesthetically it's
more in line with how it was around the
turn of the 20th century gas street
lights stand on every corner and the
Modern Skyscrapers of the business
district are recreated in the style of
Victorian architecture the epicenter of
construction appears to be the houses of
Parliament which is evidenced by the
more unfinished and flawed the city
becomes further out from the center one
goes some of the buildings are made of
nonsensical materials like copper pipes
and some of the gas lamps are nothing
more than a ball of disembodied light
floating atop a metal pole the first big
question that the foundation had upon
discovering this location was of course
why on Earth was it created and they
wouldn't have to look far as an
explanation of this bizarre mirror City
plays automatically upon entering my
fellow citizen if you are hearing this
tape then the world as we know it is
finished the sky has broken the ground
heaves with the [ __ ] of terrible feet
and all the horror and Madness from the
dark corners of the world has broken
free to exact its Vengeance on the world
of man evil has raised its bloody flag
upon all nations of the world and crowd
its Unholy Victory to the broken Sky yes
this is the end but there is a New Hope
welcome to unlondon a city of survivors
a city of the free together fellow
citizen we will wait and prepare for the
new beginning the grand new world that
is soon to come let the world above burn
we will endure that the monsters have
the world we will prepare we will wait
and I tell you citizen that there will
be a new morning and you will emerge
from UNL London and stand blinking in
the Sun and on that day citizen there
shall be a new order as we raise the
Union flag over the entire world I
welcome you to a London the last City
and the first from this message it seems
that this mirror city was built to be a
refuge for survivors of an apocalyptic
scenario but the SCP Foundation had no
knowledge of such a plan in fact it's
still unknown who created this place or
how they did it the one fact that was
evident to the foundation was that even
though this strange place was intended
to be a safe haven it was far too poorly
constructed to actually act as one
illumination was unreliable and most of
the buildings were damp and infested
with mold it's also unclear to the
foundation where the oxygen and gas
supply of unlonden was coming from
throughout the day the loudspeakers
around unlondon play automated messages
such as says No One Is Safe from the
influence of memetic beings Bryson's
home for the pole is here to help and
crime will not be tolerated in UNL
London the tormentors of society will
become its Defenders at the end of every
hour that passes the speakers announced
the time followed by and all is well
when the SCP Foundation first entered on
London it was unknown whether or not any
living things inhabited the city on
first investigation it seemed from its
state of disrepair that the city had
been long abandoned but soon the
foundation met their first inhabitants
of the underground city mobile task
force members were inspecting the area
around the houses of Parliament when
they discovered what looked to be a bank
as they approached the doors they heard
the following announcement over the
nearby loudspeakers citizen you are
entering a restricted area have your
authorization papers ready a Bobby will
arrive to escort you shortly this
signaled the approach of SC
1678-a also known as the Bobbies a
single instance of
scp-1678-a appeared with the
unmistakable sound of a police whistle
and as soon as it arrived it started
attacking the members of the task force
another announcement came over the
speakers police part criminal the
Bobbies are the main threat to visitors
in on London and they will attack on
site with any improvised weapon they can
find true to their name they are all
dressed in uniforms consistent with
those of London city police officers
from the Victorian era what sets them
apart from their historical counterparts
is their construction these beings are
made out of human corpses crudely
dismembered at the joints and
reassembled using metal hinges and bolts
with their heads wrapped in bandages
Bobbies are extremely hard to kill with
only High caliber rounds and explosive
weapons being effective at putting them
down autopsies of dead Bobbies have
shown that underneath the police uniform
the Bobby's all wear Prison inmate style
jumpsuits this adds a chilling context
to the announcement about the tormentors
of society becoming its Defenders it
appears that the Bobbies are the
re-animated bodies of prisoners in
addition to the Bobbies the foundation
catalog two additional forms of
artificial life present within on London
first are
scp-1678- P or eyes in the sky hybrid
biomechanical birds made of Flesh with
an exoskeleton of copper wiring some of
these creatures are covered in a
deteriorating outer layer of plastic and
Feathers suggesting that they were
originally meant to resemble pigeons as
their name suggests eyes in the sky
serve as a type of surveillance drone
and while they have no offensive
capabilities they still pose a
significant threat to the foundation
it's still unclear whether they're able
to communicate with or summon the
Bobbies but the SCP Foundation takes no
chances the last life form present in
scp-16 78 is the strangest and the most
frightening as CP
1678-c known as the wretch the wretch
has only ever been encountered outside
the Zone which is now under SCP
Foundation control and it's uncertain
how many instances of this being exist
the wretch resembles an old woman or
sometimes old man dressed in filthy rags
the red sits at street corners holding a
begging tray and will attempt to elicit
pity from anyone who happens to walk by
the wretch will ask for food or money
but if food is supplied it will start
weeping before Vanishing into a puff of
black smoke on a few occasions audio
notices playing on the city's
loudspeakers have alluded to this being
saying do not pity the rich allow them
to pay the price of their betrayal for
all eternity the current Foundation
protocol with regards to the wretch is
to not engage with it at all in addition
to the Bobbies the eyes in the sky and
the wretches there's another strange
component world of on London throughout
the city in any area designed for human
habitation the foundation discovered
multiple machines that resembled modern
gas pumps these machines are fitted with
coin slots and rubber hoses that when
coins are inserted dispense a
porridge-like substance advertised as Dr
Goody's Wonder food according to posters
around the city wonder food is a meal
replacement supplement supposedly
containing all of the required nutrients
for survival Wonder food also appears to
be the only food source available in on
London despite the claims by various
posters around the city that Wonder food
contains all the nutrients you need and
completely restores health and vitality
examination of this substance has
revealed that it is much like the rest
of UNL London unsuitable for sustaining
life tests have confirmed that Wonder
food is a synthetic starch gel heavily
enriched with various minerals vitamins
fats and bulking agents and it contains
artificially engineered DNA Helix
structures while it does contain all the
elements required for short-term
survival consuming the product for
longer than six weeks will result in
severe malnutrition and eventually
scurvy further tests have shown that
Wonder food also contains psychoactive
properties the porridge contains a
mixture of unknown molecular compounds
which through regular consumption makes
subjects calmer less anxious and less
likely to resist Authority it also seems
to have been engineered to cause
withdrawal symptoms that set in if a
person stops eating it symptoms which
include headaches and depression
Foundation Personnel are forbidden to
consume Wonder food but the substance is
highly attractive to instances of
scp-1678b and 1678c like most things in
a London the quality of Wonder food
varies wildly with some dispensers
putting out a product that is so
degraded that it can cause sickness
deformities or even death in the
consumer but strangely the foundation
has also recorded a type of unknown
colorful mollusk which feeds on spillage
from the Wonder food dispensers at
present on London is only partially
contained mobile task forces tau-4 and
Epsilon 6 have succeeded in establishing
a perimeter around the Hyde Park
District where they have managed to stop
any incursion from
scp-1678-a even though this is the only
area that is fully under Foundation
control Explorations have been conducted
of buildings outside that perimeter the
investigations are vital for the
foundation's main purpose in UNL London
which is figuring out who built it and
exactly what kind of event this
underground mirror city was meant to
prepare for the interior of the Natural
History Museum yielded particularly
strange insights into the purpose of on
London for the most part the museum is
close to how it appears in the above
ground but with one key difference the
task force investigating the museum
discovered an exhibit called the fall of
Man exactly where the Darwin Wing should
have been the exhibit as its name
suggests details the apocalyptic
scenario that would have theoretically
driven people underground into on London
but to everyone's surprise its dioramas
and displays didn't depict an asteroid
impact plague or nuclear Armageddon to
the foundation task force members the
scenes of Destruction depicted in the
exhibit were far more familiar they
recognized The Reptilian form of scp-682
the ordinary looking Brownstone basement
door that serves as a gateway to
scp-2317 and most chillingly the
imposing many-eyed figure of the Scarlet
King these were only some of the known
cutter class scps depicted in the museum
exhibit it was clear that even though
the SCP Foundation hadn't built this
city whoever did knew a lot about the
SCP foundation's activities it's
believed by the foundation that whoever
or whatever created on London still
resides in the houses of Parliament and
the ultimate goal of the task forces is
to infiltrate the building but in order
to do that they will first need to find
where the Bobbies are made and Halt and
production it's believed that Bryson's
home for the poor is where they
originate from but it's unclear exactly
where the materials to make them come
from nor is it clear just how they're
produced ultimately the foundation's
goal is to catalog the entire city and
once they have stopped the production of
more Bobbies mtft4 and Epsilon 6 will
storm the houses of Parliament and
contain whatever Force has created on
London but London is a very big city and
unlonden is just as big so there's no
telling what else they might find
exploring this bizarre location have you
ever had a nightmare that you're running
down a long dark hallway getting chased
by something you can't see the thing
behind you isn't fast but that doesn't
matter you can't run forever and the
thing knows it it is a patient Predator
it toys with its food at first you move
with speed and Rhythm the metallic
scraping noise behind you grows quieter
you run and stumble through the dark you
your muscles start to ache and your
lungs burn your pace slows it's still
coming you can hear the scraping getting
louder you start to Panic it's
completely dark you don't know where
you're running or even what you're
running from all you know as you bump
against the walls and the sharp Corners
that Rush towards you is that you can't
run forever you trip fall and pain
explodes through your legs as your knee
shatters on the concrete ground that
scraping is getting louder you can
barely breathe you can't run anymore
with your injury there's no way to stop
what's coming there is no escape the
scraping is right behind you you scream
and then you wake up your heart is
pounding like thunder in your chest and
your sheets are soaked with sweat but
you're safe you're out of those awful
dark hallways but what if this wasn't
just a nightmare what if this scenario
was real and there was no escape from
the horror chasing you in the Darkness
that's what it's like to have a close
encounter with
scp-1918 a sadistic sentient object that
loves playing Twisted games with its
prey but this monster never plays fair
and even worse it's always just a simple
door away it may even be hiding behind a
door near you right now waiting to start
a game with its new playmate but soon
you'll understand why some doors should
never ever be opened and why some games
are better left unplayed
scp-1918 is an anomaly with two parts
scp-1918 itself and
scp-1918-2 the monster's underground
lair the duo are a match made in hell as
the chambers and hallways of 1918-2 are
perfectly tailored to 1918's Violent
Hobbies nobody knows how long this
anomaly has been operating but it's
probably behind countless disappearances
after all 1918 has a habit of breaking
its toys the nightmare began in a small
town in Maine with a population of only
226 people but that population was about
to get lower people in the town began to
report strange noises at night a droning
metal on concrete scraping noise like
someone dragging a lead pipe along the
ground at first people just ignored the
sound it was all in their heads or maybe
just a faulty oven or a washing machine
on the fritz anything that would allow
them to forget about the noise and get
on with their daily lives but the noises
were coming from below they could be
heard out on the streets most audibly
near manholes and Sewer grates people
started feeling unsafe in their homes
the noises were spooking animals and
children people were losing sleep that's
scraping they all tried to ignore was
beginning to get to them all letters
emails and angry phone calls to the Town
Council were piling up something had to
be done before the whole town went crazy
with fear the mayor authorized four
utility workers to investigate the
source of the noise at a local sewage
treatment facility considering the
scraping was loudest near the sewer
grates everyone just assumed that
whatever was causing all this must be
connected to the sewers four utility
workers were sent to investigate the
facility only to find that the Machinery
on site was working just fine the source
of the problems must have been coming
directly from the underground sewer
lines themselves the four workers
equipped with headlamps descended into a
long service tunnel that fed into the
sewer system as they pass deeper into
the tunnel the darkness around them
became thicker it was a tangible
presence that drowned out the light of
their headlamps similar to the anomalous
phenomenon exhibited by
scp-087 when the utility workers tried
to turn back they discovered another
impossibility it seemed that the tunnel
behind them had become a solid Kong
Crete wall they were trapped but where
it was too dark to tell confused and
terrified the four men stuck together
attempting to find a way out it was too
dark to see their hand in front of their
face so all they could do was navigate
Slowly by feeling the walls around them
these walls felt old crusty there was a
kind of faint metallic stench hanging in
the air too like old blood something
horrible had happened here and something
horrible was about to happen again all
they could do was keep moving and try to
stay calm eventually after hours of
pawing at the walls in the dark they
found an open doorway one by one they
filed inside only to feel blinded when
bright white ceiling lights suddenly
switched on the room was all white and
filled with pipes large and small
running from wall to wall just then one
of the utility workers let out an ear
splitting scream and pointed towards the
doorway his colleagues turned and gasped
and
there was something outside the door and
it was staring at them the object filled
up almost the entire doorway it seemed
like a demonic hobby horse made from a
black and white candy striped metal pole
with a crude plastic head on top the
head looked like a clowns with a wide
toothy grin but no visible eyes it was
scp-1918. the utility workers were
frozen as the object leaned forward
slightly and slithered into the room the
bottom of the metal pipes scraping
against the ground it was the exact same
scraping noise that had been haunting
the concern townsfolk up above this was
the thing behind it all and as the
object moved its metal poles started to
scrape words into the ground Tic Tac Toe
none of the four utility workers were
ever seen again it didn't take long for
the SCP Foundation to descend upon this
quiet main town and pick up the pieces
all relevant officials were were
provided them knee sticks and cover
stories were created for the
disappearances of the four utility
workers the foundation also commandeered
the sewage treatment facility that held
the entrance to
scp-1918-2 replacing all key roles at
the facility with undercover Foundation
Personnel
scp-1918 was given a Euclid
classification due to the fixed nature
of its hunting grounds and then the real
research began the foundation soon made
some disturbing discoveries entrances
into the
scp-1918-2 area didn't follow any kind
of logic the hunting ground of scp-1918
can be entered from almost any location
if you're unlucky enough there are
currently nine known entrances including
five sewage grates three utility shafts
located in a sewage facility and one
toilet and these are just the ones that
the foundation knows about there are a
huge number of ways to enter
scp-1918-2 but to this day nothing has
ever been able to leave
scp-1918-2 is contained 20 meters below
the streets of this unassuming main Town
Personnel aside from Foundation approved
d-class guinea pigs a refused entrance
researchers have mapped out the layout
of 1918-2 through seismic Imaging of
scp-1918's movements there are 18
identical room pairs in
scp-1918-2 or nine compound rooms rooms
are differentiated between a one room
and a two room by crude carvings on the
floors outside of the individual rooms
scp-1918-2 is symmetrical with half a
meter wide path circling each compound
room the only deviation to this
construction are the location of
entrances on the sides of each
individual room which very randomly
while the location is active what
exactly does scp-1918 do in this private
little maze it plays games of course its
two favorites as indicated by the words
it scrapes into the round are Tic Tac
Toe and memory in tic-tac-toe 1918 moves
to each one room leaving behind X
markings on the floors if the room is
not already marked with an o in a manner
similar to a game of tic-tac-toe how a
victim is meant to accomplish making a
Mark or understanding this process is
unknown as no AIDS are given blood is
commonly used by victims to make their
markings hence the rusty smell in many
of the rooms in memory the trapped
victim is rendered unconscious by blunt
force presumably from scp-1918 the
subject regains Consciousness in a
random section of the facility success
is marked by finding a one room
identical to the central room this event
seems to possess a time limit as the
subject is pursued by scp-1918 through
the halls of the facility the subject
wins by marking the correct room with an
O what happens if you win or lose these
games it's important to note that
scp-1918 is very competitive and doesn't
play fair if you win the object will
merely accuse you of cheating and start
a new game this will happen again and
again until eventually you lose and what
do you do well take the horrifying
encounter d-class Personnel member d2934
had with
scp-1918 wearing video and audio
equipment d2934 was led into
scp-1918-2 by Foundation researchers
when he eventually found his way to the
central room 1918 challenged him to a
game of Tic-tac-toe and Against All Odds
d-2934 won the game but 1918 didn't take
kindly to that it accused d2934 of
cheating carving its accusations into
the ground before challenging him to a
deadly game of memory after hours of
chasing d-2934 eventually lost his mind
and was backed into a corner by 1918 as
the object made its way towards him he
panicked ripped a pipe from the wall and
began smashing 1918's head as the
plastic cracked under the force of the
blows Foundation scientists could see
real brains inside
d2934 screamed and the video feed cut
off when the video turned back on
sometime later 1918 stared into the
camera with a different head mounted
atop its metal pole one that just a few
hours earlier had belonged to the
unfortunate
d2934 if there's one lesson to be
learned from this terrifying anomaly
it's that there truly Is No Escape from
scp-1918. you're on a road trip the kind
that stretches over days on end and you
need to make multiple stops along the
way to refuel the car and yourself the
last time you remember stopping to get
more gas and a bite to eat was back in
Wyoming and now you're in the heart of
Montana thankfully like in a way basis
in the desert you see the town of
Clearwater off in the distance it's a
vibrant welcoming little place a perfect
slice of classic small town Americana
you took a similar trip last year and
vaguely remember stopping at Clearwater
that time too and you're glad to be back
in particular you remember the old
Prairie Diner a folksy little place with
the most delicious Huckleberry pie you
ever tasted perhaps it's about time for
you to give it another try you fill up
your tank and stop at the diner the food
tastes just as good as you remember but
one thing is off the entire staff seems
to have changed it is the exact same
Diner you ate a year ago no doubt about
that but it looks like everyone from the
wait staff to the cashier to the cooks
have all been replaced you try your best
not to think about it after all
businesses are allowed to replace their
staff but the longer you sit in the
diner the more uncomfortable the
feelings become you need to ask someone
just to push away the fears that you're
not not going crazy when the waiter
passes by you compliment the food and
mention you ate here last year too you
asked the unfamiliar waiter if they had
worked here back then they confirmed
that yes they've always worked here and
and so has everybody else the diner is a
family business you leave town not too
long after that feeling vaguely
unsettled and as a voice on the radio
warns about the incoming rain you tell
yourself that you never want to return
to the town of Clearwater Montana as you
leave the memory of the Town seems to
fade from your mind in real time but
little do you know the people of
Clearwater will never be able to leave
ever it's because something horrifying
will happen in Clearwater every single
year and that thing is known to the SCP
Foundation as
scp-3300 this annual anomalous event is
Clearwater's own local curse always
occurring around mid-june while many of
the mechanics of this event still elude
the foundation's understanding the
outcome is well documented every single
inhabitant of the town is replaced by a
person who didn't previously exist while
some elements may carry over from their
original counterparts every person
involved will simply be a whole new
person with no memories of the change or
who they once were the process known as
scp-3300 lasts between 6 and 18 days and
once the process has begun it's
impossible for any Outsiders to
intervene it begins with rain a light
dreary drizzle at first but each day the
rain gets worse soon it's a storm and
then a Maelstrom flooding hurricanes
tornadoes all centered around clear
water but cutting off neatly just beyond
it what happens in Clearwater remains in
Clearwater and when the process has
concluded and The Sun Shines once more
everybody has been changed whenever the
foundation has tried to send Personnel
or equipment into Clearwater during
scp-3300 one of two things has happened
in the more favorable scenarios those
attempting to enter Clearwater have
simply appeared on the other side of the
city limits in the less positive
instances personnel and Equipment have
been lost forever within there is no
stopping or even understanding scp-3300
according to Foundation records
Clearwater has been around at least as
long as the foundation itself perhaps
even longer Clearwater has been able to
undergo its yearling nightmare without
intrusion due to a unique Cognito
hazardous effect which creates a kind of
mental block around memories of the town
for Outsiders you won't forget clear
water per se but you will find it
increasingly hard to focus on like
something you can only ever see out of
the corner of your eye there is no
saving the people of clear water the
horror will play out again and again and
again the foundation is no firsthand
knowledge of what happens in Clearwater
during those horrifying 18 days but one
account they have hints at a terrifying
possibility during an Excursion into
Clear Water the foundation managed to
collect a diary belonging to a woman
named Margaret Lane to the best of our
knowledge Margaret Lane no longer exists
but if the contents of her diary aren't
to be believed then what goes on in
Clearwater during scp-3300 is far worse
than we ever imagined Margaret first
started her diary not long before
scp-3300's 1995 iteration began she was
in the middle of a tumultuous time in
her life freshly cleaned from alcohol
and drug addiction forced to live with
her antagonistic mother and having
peculiar and distressing dreams in the
first Dream Margaret recorded she was
someone else a woman living in a small
Hut perhaps a century ago or more it was
plague time she was looking down upon
her daughter bedrin her skin covered in
painful looking red blotches her husband
was already dead that's when another man
enters a healthy man he tells her that
he's found their salvation and then the
dream ended Margaret woke up to a gray
dreary day there were clouds on the
horizon the rain was come it drizzled
for the next few days before getting
more intense as one would expect from an
scp-3300 cycle of course nothing seemed
out of place to Margaret life carried on
she continued to stay clean resisting
the offers of her old dealer though her
relationship with her mother remained
Frosty the rain started to get worse as
voices on the radio insisted that
conditions would continue to become more
severe over the next few days they tried
their best to maintain normality
Margaret invited some friends Jared Sam
Mike and Isabelle to come over and play
D D at her place that was when all hell
broke loose while the group role played
there was a furious banging at the door
like whoever was knocking was trying to
bash the door down when Margaret's mom
opened the door to investigate the
commotion she saw that an entire family
was standing there a father a mother and
two young children the father
immediately began furiously asking why
all these strangers were in his house
when Margaret's mother tried to tell him
that this wasn't his house he became
increasingly agitated and walked
straight into the home Margaret's
friends attempted to subdue him but he
threw them off displaying a supernatural
strength Margaret's mom ran in with a
golf club and struck the mysterious man
in the chest there was a nasty Splat but
he didn't seem to react the golf club
was just embedded in his chest having
broken the skin and sunken in but there
was no blood just dripping water the
father then pulled the golf club out of
his chest and began beating Margaret's
mother to death with it all while
repeating my house again and again while
his wife and children watched with broad
Sunny Smiles in the rain somehow
Margaret knew that her mother was beyond
saving and that there was no way of
defeating these things in a physical
confrontation all they could do was run
out to Jared's van with the rest of the
group and hightail it to the police
station but when they arrived at the
station the doors were barred and it
appeared empty as the torrential rain
hammered down from above there was
nothing left to do but drive out of town
and try to escape whatever Madness was
going on here but that was easier said
than done they drove for what seemed
like hours on end as the rain and the
howling wind persisted Jared had been
injured during the fight with the
strange family and his health
deteriorated further as the drive
stretched on they should have left the
town of Clearwater a long time ago but
it seemed like they were nowhere it
wasn't long before Jared was lying dead
in the back of the van and now there
were only four of them left they kept
driving afraid grieving hungry and tired
and Margaret took the opportunity to
sleep it was no time to rest but she was
so exhausted that she had no choice
Margaret had a continuation of her
earlier dream the different her the
dream her was laying the plague-ridden
body of her daughter in the river but
she wasn't the only one all the Villages
of her settlement were placing the
bodies of their dead in the river as the
water washed around them and through
them the bodies became one with the
water and then they became the water the
water was everything when Margaret awoke
it was to the horrifying sounds of
bubbling and boiling that's when she saw
that Jared's body was dissolving now not
dissolving evaporating it was bubbling
and convulsing like it was made of water
until the entire thing burst into a
Cascade of hot steam after that Margaret
and the others left the vehicle and
refused to get back inside nothing was
making sense it was like something out
of a nightmare as they walked the rain
hammered down upon them they couldn't
have been walking for more than a mile
when they crashed into something it was
a sign welcome to Clear Water it was
like that the town itself had drawn them
back Mike refused to return to the town
of his own free will and began walking
in the other direction moments later he
was walking back towards them in silence
though he'd never end 2. scp-3300 had
distorted his path and brought him back
it was clear that Mike was shaken to the
core by the experience but they had to
press on they would head to the grocery
store for food and then to a sporting
goods store where they could hopefully
grab some guns to fight the violent
altered people who'd somehow appeared
with the rain but things didn't go to
plan or what little plan there even was
Mike shot himself on the first night at
Dirk's Sporting Goods leaving only
Margaret Sam and Isabelle alive perhaps
one of the most terrifying details of
Mike's death was the fact he didn't even
bleed instead the gaping exit wound in
the back of his head was just full of
water water was all that seemed to be
left of them Sam seemingly driven to the
Edge by the sight of Mike's death
grabbed a hunting knife to perform an
experiment she'd cut it into her own
skin and was horrified to see only water
dripping out they'd all been changed and
they didn't know why that's when the
survivors noticed something else there
were people standing outside in the rain
hundreds of them not a single one they
could recognize all new people waiting
Sam said only one word outside before
walking out of the hunting goods store
and disappearing into the crowd and the
rain never to be seen Again Margaret
Muse that perhaps in the end she had the
right idea to be taken killed or raced
or changed would be inevitable in the
final entry in Margaret's diary dreams
blend with reality as her mind finally
gives out from the terror she realizes
in her final moments that there is no
way out there is no Escape there is only
water water is eternal the rain is
eternal all will be changed and given
the fact that no trace of Margaret was
ever found saved for her diary all her
fears turned out to be right she was
taken and replaced by scp-3300 just as
will inevitably happen to all the
current citizens of Clearwater the next
time scp-3300 rolls around it will be as
inevitable and as indifferent to those
it affects as tomorrow's sunrise you
cannot change the rain but believe us in
Clearwater Montana the rain can change
you you're driving down a long Highway
lost in an area you don't know too well
trying to find the right turn that'll
have you heading back towards your home
you keep driving the nighttime quiet all
around you deciding to try and break
that silence you reach for the radio
turning the dial to filter through all
the garbled distorted voices and songs
from nearby local radio stations that
are too far out of range to come through
clearly you try your best to listen to
the music from One radio station but
eventually the sound of the static only
makes you wish for the silence you were
trying to break your fingers nudge the
tuning dial on your car radio once again
and finally something comes through it
isn't loud or clear but under the
Distortion you can make out the sound
and it isn't a song or even a late news
broadcast the first thing you hear
sounds like a short musical tone only
for about 10 seconds next a young girl's
voice speaking in a language you don't
understand even through the distorted
audio from her accent you assume it's
Russian but you still have no idea what
the word she's saying mean with nothing
else to listen to you let the broadcast
play still driving alone in the dark
with nothing but the strange adolescent
voice to accompany you your mind begins
to wander she sounds like she's speaking
something but the rhythm of the words is
somehow familiar to you even though you
don't speak Russian then it hits you
she's counting but you don't feel smart
for having worked that out instead
something about knowing that makes your
blood run cold you carry on driving
through the night after a few short
minutes the Russian girl stops counting
and the musical tone plays again under
the Distortion leaving you alone in the
car once again with nothing but your
thoughts and questions of what exactly
you just heard thankfully we have the
answer what you heard was
scp-3034 since 1964 this same broadcast
has been made a vast number of times
627 times in fact you'd have to be
within two kilometers of the broadcast's
point of origin to hear it where
Foundation Personnel have tried and
failed numerous times to triangulate its
source the numbers heard recited in the
scp-3034 broadcast are actually a
countdown from 200 read aloud in Russian
all Foundation staff are able to do
while stationed at the nearby
provisional site 3034 as scour radio
frequencies for occurrences of
scp-3034 checking their equipment is
properly maintained and calibrated
before they are eventually rotated off
site and replaced with a new group of
staff there is only one rule that any
foundation members working at
provisional site 3034 must follow they
are only permitted to send one radio
transmission with their equipment a
single phrase in reply to the scp-3034
broadcast
receiving this the countdown stops and
the broadcast ends but never permanently
scp-3034 has been known to repeatedly
occur seemingly at random the shortest
recorded gap between broadcasts was two
weeks while the longest so far lasted
six whole months you may have heard the
term Numbers Station mentioned before
but these are far from just random
numerical sequences sent out over the
airwaves without purpose General
speculation surrounding number stations
points to them being the tools of
Espionage agents a way of sending coded
highly sensitive messages or information
without the risk of compromising their
cover the use of number station
Transmissions is often attributed to
spies working on foreign soil who
utilize shortwave radio frequencies
speech synthesis Morse code and either
regular or sporadic timing schedules
while it's true that times have changed
and technology has progressed
considerably there appears to be
evidence that number stations are still
used among various intelligence and
Espionage agencies today despite being
considered an old-fashioned method of
communication these low-tech shortwave
stations remain a viable reliable option
for the transmission and reception of
intelligence to field agents the ConEd
project is a comprehensive Archive of
this phenomenon and its founder Aiken
Fernandez has long been fascinated by
number stations according to him this
system is completely secure because the
messages can't be tracked the recipient
could be anywhere you just send spies to
the country and get them to buy a radio
they know where to tune and when so what
does the distorted broadcast of numbers
from scp-3034 mean is the work of covert
agents and if so whose side are they on
most importantly why does the SCP
Foundation make certain there are always
three of its Personnel on site ready to
send the all is well message whenever
scp-3034 begins broadcasting
scp-3034 was first discovered by the
foundation in 1964 after a Defector from
the Soviet grup a division tasked with
acquiring and studying anomalies on
behalf of the USSR gave them a temp
Commander Robert malphus along with a
team of six including a man named agent
Browning selected for his knowledge of
Russian dialects were sent to
investigate at provisional site 3034
here the team uncovered partially burned
records and log books all kept in
Russian along with evidence that the
site had been evacuated shortly before
their arrival carved into a desk also in
Russian were two phrases don't let her
finish and tell her all is well on the
team's second day at the site an
automated alarm sounded at 7 30 am
alerting them to the incoming scp-3034
broadcast following the instructions on
the desk agent Browning was able to stop
the broadcast telling the young Russian
girl that all was well a tape was
partially recovered by the team from the
site and translated from Russian the
grup members that had previously
inhabited the station had interrogated
one of their own a man named Sergey whom
they accused of stealing State Property
she's not State Property he replied she
has a name while his grup Superior
accused Sergey of planning to defect to
the United States allegedly in exchange
for money and Asylum Sergey denied any
collusion with America he claimed that
the grup at provisional site-3034 were
meddling with powers they could not
possibly hope to understand his Superior
a man named vaslav dismiss this claiming
their work to be no different to the
United States experimentation with
atomic weapons at the time one does not
make deals with atom bombs Sergey arcade
one certainly does not sacrifice little
girls to them shortly after this a
struggle broke out with Sergey having to
be restrained while urging vaslov to
cease any and all interference with it
the man spoke of terrible nightmares
that he'd had voices screaming in the
darkness that's what they once was love
that's what it is you cannot make a deal
with this team we have finally contained
it and now you want to offer it the
tapes audio ends shortly after this
point with no clear answer as to what
Sergey was referring to or what offered
these Russian operatives had made to it
ever since the discovery of scp-3034
members of the SCP Foundation have
worked tirelessly to understand the
purpose of these countdowns as well as
determine their origin by September 2012
Dr shokil was reaching the end of his
tether with the investigation into the
scp-3034 broadcast over almost half a
century the foundation had made well
over 600 recordings of the Russian girls
countdowns but still hadn't determined
any noteworthy information they were
prohibited from contacting the girl via
the same radio frequency only permitted
to use the phrase that stopped her
countdowns running out of options she'll
kill contacted his colleague Dr Emerson
asking for an in-depth vocal analysis of
the various recordings of
scp-3034 even if they could narrow down
where the broadcast was coming from
Maybe by determining the girl's
geographical location from her dialect
then that would be at least some slight
progress into understanding
scp-3034 while unable to discover the
girl's location Dr Emerson's analysis
did yield some interesting findings
Emerson learned that these countdowns
were not pre-recorded the variations in
the Russian girl's voice her tone her
pitch all seemed to indicate that every
instance of the broadcast was unique
rather than use the same recording this
girl had been counting down over and
over hundreds of times for almost 50
years but there was more shulkill and
Emerson then examined the Distortion The
Sounds interfering with the audio of the
Russian girls countdowns what had
initially seemed like garbled static
seemed to actually be additional voices
and much like the girl's voice these
distorted voices were unique different
in every broadcast however show kill and
Emerson were unable to accurately
determine what these voices were saying
given that the girls countdowns were
always cut short by the use of the
phrase all is well the doctors did not
have long enough samples of the audio to
analyze the other distorted voices with
permission from the foundation the next
five occurrences of the scp-3034
broadcast were allowed to carry on for
longer giving the two doctors enough
audio to determine exactly what the
distorted voices were and the results
were extremely troubling they were
screams thousands upon thousands of
children's voices endlessly screaming
both Dr Emerson and Dr shulkill agreed
that it would be best to continue
responding to scp-3034 with the correct
phrase and refused to analyze the
distorted screaming audio any further
three years later while stationed at
provisional site 3034 a foundation
researcher named Dr Uriel Willis decided
to take matters into her own hands she
conducted an experiment that had not
been sanctioned by the foundation and
attempted to make contact with a Russian
girl giving the countdowns hearing Dr
Willis's voice the girl stopped her
countdown after five long painfully
silent seconds a new broadcast was heard
a piercing high-pitched Screech that
caused extreme pain and dizziness to all
the staff working on site unable to Bear
the disorienting sound Dr Willis told
the girl all is well and caused the
noise to stop the following day SCP
researchers noted that there had been a
significant increase in cases of missing
children all around the world a majority
of these disappearances happened at the
same time the Screech had been broadcast
and remain unsolved to this day Dr
Willis faced disciplinary action from
the SCP Foundation and any further
testing of scp-3034 and attempts to
communicate with the Russian girl were
prohibited only one distinct change has
been noted in the scp-3034 broadcast
since this incident almost a month later
the countdown was detected in the
correct phrase given but researchers
noted that instead of starting her
countdown from 200 this time the Russian
girl began counting down from 199.
nobody knows what will happen if the
Russian girls countdown is allowed to
reach zero Personnel working at
provisional site-3030 4 are told to
always offer her the necessary phrase
before this point in the countdown
attempting to interfere with the
broadcast by contacting this girl
directly not only resulted in intense
pain for SCP staff but also seems to
have caused an unconfirmed number of
child disappearances around the globe as
well as reducing the countdown starting
number from 200 to 199. after a long
night on the road you finally find the
right turn sending you in the right
direction as you drive through the night
you keep telling yourself one thing one
small phrase over and over again you
hope the words will eventually give you
comfort but deep down you start to
realize just how hollow they are that
it's just a lie we tell ourselves so we
don't have to face the inevitable but
still what choice do you have but to
keep telling yourself that all is well
the year was 1857 and the second Opium
War was raging between China and the
combined forces of the English and
French it was one of the many bloody
colonial wars fought over resources like
tea sugar and the intoxicating Opium
poppy it was a war fought by peasants
and noblemen alike one of these
aristocratic soldiers was the noble Lord
Theodore Thomas Blackwood the
quintessential English gentleman and
Explorer while his fellow soldiers
cowered behind cover Lord Blackwood
charged Into The Fray shouldering his
rifle and firing his pistol into the
crowd of opposing soldiers it was the
Battle of Canton one of the most crucial
battles of the entire conflict the
French and English were laying Siege to
the City of Canton also known as
Guangzhou to prove their military
dominance and capture an important
Chinese government official Lord
Blackwood led the charge on Horseback
every bullet seemed to find the heart of
a foe he was a true hero among men a
gentleman warrior with class refinement
and style and it would be thanks to his
expert leadership and Marksmanship on
the field that the Allied European
forces won the battle decisively Lord
Theodore Thomas Blackwood is a name that
deserves to be counted among Lord
Horatio Nelson Sir Francis Bacon and Sir
Walter Raleigh in addition to being a
skilled and honorable fighter Lord
Blackwood is a consummate Explorer
naturalist and Frontiersman during his
Heyday he traveled perhaps further than
any man across the known and unknown
corners of the globe he made scientific
biological and anthropological
discoveries that should have reset the
course of society forever and yet you
won't find any records in the history
books of Lord Theodore Thomas Blackwood
nor will you find any Grand oil
paintings or dedicated Wings in British
museums this is because Lord Theodore
Thomas Blackwood is a four and a half
inch telepathic neon sea slug and he's
known to the SCP Foundation as scp-18
67 while he would never admit to it Lord
Blackwood belongs to the species
nambrotha kubariana also known as the
variable neon slug he's kept in a
standard aquarium in a foundation
containment site and is physically no
different to any other member of his
species what makes Lord Blackwood unique
is his powerful telepathic abilities
specifically the power to communicate by
speaking directly into people's minds
and what's more he's extremely talkative
but to what extent is anything that this
anomalous sea slug says true or is he
just like scp-082 fernan the cannibal a
creative and pathological liar it isn't
committed to record how exactly the
foundation discovered Lord Blackwood
perhaps a local aquarium worker worried
they were going insane when they heard
the voice of a 19th century English
nobleman ringing in their ears whenever
they were cleaning algae out of the tank
maybe Lord Blackwood was found by SCP
Foundation divers we're constantly
combing the ocean for anomalous
creatures and activity what we do know
is that Lord Blackwood is an incredibly
strange and mysterious individual he
claims to have visited locations all
around the world and encountered rare
societies and creatures the foundation
was skeptical about a number of Lord
blackwood's more outlandish claims on
account of him being a sea slug but he
does appear to have the knowledge to
back up his supposed experience
interviews with Lord Blackwood have
shown that he's extremely knowledgeable
in the areas of geography zoology botany
archeology anthropology and Linguistics
relating to his claim regions of
exploration as well as more esoteric
Fields such as obscure mythology
mysticism and cryptozoology in other
words if Lord Blackwood hadn't gone on
his escapades around the globe
throughout history how would he have
come to possess this wide variety of
information the foundation was getting
frustrated and began to probe further
into the personal life of the most
interesting gastropod in containment
Lord Blackwood under questioning was
always polite and amicable with
Foundation staff he seemed to display no
real knowledge of the fact that he
himself was a sea slug going as far to
accuse other people of being crazy or
drunk when they brought the fact up to
him while none of Lord blackwood's tall
tales ever extend past the year 1910. he
told fanciful stories of exploring the
Americas and of his involvement in the
second Opium War on the side of the
English naturally the foundation wanted
proof when they pressured Lord Blackwood
on this something even stranger happened
he gave it the Lord told his
interviewers that he would happily
donate his collection to them if it gave
them cause to believe what he was saying
he gave the baffled Foundation
researchers the address of a cottage in
England where they could find the
secrets to his bizarre and mysterious
past and local agents in the area
followed up on the information upon
investigation Foundation field agents
did indeed find the cot outage that Lord
Blackwood had specified it was being
maintained by an extremely old woman
when questioned about her presence there
she said that she was keeping the house
for Lord Blackwood and gave no more
useful information incidentally it
appears that this singular purpose was
all that this old woman was living for
she abruptly passed away from heart
failure five days after the foundation
commandeered the cottage whether
anything truly anomalous caused this we
still do not know at first the cottage
seemed normal until the field agents
discovered a secret basement housing
Lord blackwoods collection they were
amazed at what they saw the basement
consisted of Zoological and Botanical
specimens over 3000 artifacts a library
containing over 5 000 items and a
functioning 1800s scientific laboratory
it took about three weeks for foundation
agents working Round the Clock in shifts
to remove all the items from Lord
blackwood's mysterious collection and
what they found raised even more
questions the collection included but
was no means limited to 116 unknown
species of plants 107 unknown species of
insects 28 unknown species of lizards 23
unknown species of fish 14 unknown
species of amphibians 12 unknown species
of mammals fossils pertaining to eight
unknown species of dinosaur fossils
pertaining to 12 unknown species of
prehistoric mammal and artifacts
belonging to 29 unknown indigenous
societies that's a lot of unknowns but
wait there's more his collection also
contained a collection of seemingly
unknown Firearms including three wide
bore muskets marked as Dr b t moth's
effective particle destabilizers
detailed Globes of Mercury Venus Mars
and the Galilean moons accompanied by
notes detailing possible Paths of
surface exploration a heavily modified
Carriage containing instruments of
unknown purpose a note attached to the
door reads on the front threats speak
with Henry and a highly dangerous and
seemingly anomalous machine that killed
four Foundation field agents before it
was destroyed on site and when
questioned about this little Fiasco Lord
Blackwood responded why did warn you to
be careful around my collection that
bloody thing nearly took my head off
back in 97 when I found it however there
was one thing recovered from Lord
blackwood's collection that was perhaps
more interesting than all the others 35
handwritten journals containing
recordings of events described by Lord
Blackwood in his grandiose Tall Tales to
the foundation researchers the accounts
are generally identical to the stories
he had told save for some slight
variations and exaggerations on the part
of Blackwood in the retelling most
interestingly of all all of these
journals have been dated to the
appropriate time period of the events
described by Foundation scientists while
his stories are too numerous to all be
shared here there's one that perfectly
sums them all up Lord blackwood's
account of a possible encounter with
scp-1000 also known as Bigfoot in
Seattle during the mid-1800s Lord
Blackwood seeking to explore the
so-called new world of North America
embarked with an assistant and an
indigenous American Guide to the Pacific
Northwest in search of the legendary
Sasquatch the trio was headed for Mount
Rainier then known as Tahoma during the
journey Lord Blackwood found a young fox
caught in a trap that had been set by a
local tribe he took sympathy on the
animal and freed it allowing it to run
away to safety that night he and his
assistant met up with the rest of his
guide's tribe and they settled down for
the evening however things took a
disastrous turn when the camp was raided
by a rival tribe almost everyone was
slaughtered in the process and Lord
Blackwood and his two companions were
hauled Away by the enemy tribe for a
Sinister purpose sacrifice to a violent
local deity as it turns out the creature
that this tribe worshiped was the very
same one Lord Blackwood and the others
were trying to find a particular large
and aggressive Sasquatch each night a
different sacrifice was made to the
Sasquatch the victim would be placed
near a forest clearing while the tribe
played a primal song and the Sasquatch
would emerge from the trees to devour
its prey the first night it ate the
assistant the next night it ate the
guide and then it became time for the
sacrifice of Lord Blackwood himself as
Blackwood was presented for sacrifice he
accepted his fate but instead of the
Sasquatch a legion of woodland animals
emerged from the trees foxes Elks
raccoons and more themselves painted
with tribal symbols the animals seemed
to be on Lord blackwood's side and
attacked the tribes people who had been
holding him captive giving Blackwood the
chance to flee into the forest during
the chaos later these same animals would
find Blackwood again and present him
with things his captors had stolen from
him an elder FOX also gave him a letter
proclaiming him a knight of their people
now he was allowed safe passage back to
a nearby settlement at which point he
wrote to his financiers back in England
explaining the situation and asking for
more money to perform further
Expeditions into the Tahoma region the
whole incident had only increased his
thirst for adventure and exploration
whether this tale is actually true or
just a bizarre Colonial fantasy from the
pathological Mind of a telepathic sea
slug we may never know but it doesn't
make it any less interesting to this day
Lord Blackwood continues to be a
perplexing but fascinating anomaly he
may not be the most dangerous and he may
not be the most useful either but
there's no denying that perhaps we'd all
like to sit next to his tank for a
couple hours one day and hear him spin a
good yarn over a warm cup of tea there's
a quote that says the beautiful thing
about learning is nobody can take it
away from you but what good is learning
if the knowledge might hurt you drive
you mad or even kill you it just sits
the there in your mind like a stick of
dynamite with an invisible fuse it could
blow at any moment all it take is a
careless slip of the tongue and you
might turn into a talking Home Appliance
this is a conundrum faced by anyone
dealing with an info Hazard a certain
kind of anomaly often dealt with by the
SCP Foundation before we get into some
of the craziest examples of info hazards
and what they've done to people because
let's face it that's what you're really
here for first we have to answer that
big question everyone's a little afraid
to ask just what is an info Hazard and
how does it differ from a far more
common type of SCP the dreaded Cognito
Hazard well we're glad you're finally
brave enough to ask first Cognito
hazards are anomalies that are dangerous
to perceive through one of the senses a
well-known example is
scp-096 which is actually a visual
Cognito Hazard you see its face and your
toast it's a simple as that Incognito
hazards exist for all of the other
senses too hearing taste touch even
smell info hazards on the other hand are
different these anomalous effects are
triggered when you start trying to
express or describe something about what
you've perceived and when you do things
start to get really weird really fast
maybe you're trying to explain what you
just saw to family members friends or
the police maybe you're a member of SCP
Foundation staff trying to write up a
report or a new experiment log or maybe
you're a YouTube channel trying to
create entertaining yet informative
breakdowns and explanations of anomalies
from the SCP Foundation if any or all of
these apply to you then info hazards are
going to be your worst enemy but as we
look at some of the strangest examples
we'll try our best to resist their
effects first seeing as it's so hot out
how about we take a relaxing dip in the
pool while we tell you all about
scp-1128 what is is scp-1128 well that's
a loaded question technically speaking
it's a massive predatory aquatic
creature but despite its huge size the
creature can hunt its prey in any body
of water whether you're stepping in a
puddle relaxing in the bath or say
chilling out in the pool
scp-1128 can track you down and
potentially Eat You Alive in one
particularly horrifying test a d-class
was drinking from a simple glass of
water when the Aquatic Predator emerged
yank them inside and ate them okay so
maybe you're feeling a little nervous
now but don't worry you're still safe
some people have even survived their
attacks from scp-1128 while their
initial attacks anyway the creature has
a tendency to come back again and again
Relentless and its ravenous hunger for
human flesh whenever it attacks
successfully all that's left is some
blood floating on the water but again
please don't worry too much about this
creature we don't have another their 682
on our hands after all it's an info
Hazard it can only start hunting you if
you receive a written or verbal
description of the creature oh or some
kind of visual representation of the
creature too actually on second thought
you might want to get out of the pool
now and put down that drink too instead
let us tell you a nice little story you
step into a bar spelling of fine liquor
and Rich mahogany you even get a whiff
of some fine leather-bound book you see
us sitting at the bar motioning for you
to come over and you decide to approach
you're intrigued by Our Winning smile
and our vast knowledge of anomalies and
SCP Foundation lore you take a seat next
to us and order a drink get something
fancy it's on our tab after all our
treat what does this have to do with
info hazards you ask
that's the thing about
scp-1893 kid we say our dulcet tones
smoother than Scotch you can never just
talk about it it's an info Hazard that
forces information about it to be
delivered like a story that's why we're
in the spa right now that's the setup it
expresses actual information about
itself through the dialogue see you nod
beginning to grasp the concept as the
bartender serves you your drink it's
been forever since you've been to a bar
feels good to be out again honestly you
drink deeply savoring the flavor but you
almost choke when you see the man
standing in the corner he's so large and
so distinctive it surprises you that you
hadn't noticed him before now he stands
in the corner a freakishly tall and
muscular guy like a basketball player
who decided to become a pro bodybuilder
his muscular arms are bulging out of his
white vest and a pair of bulls horns are
tattooed across the top of his bald head
making him look like devil made flesh he
stares at you with a subdued kind of
annoyance as if to say that you're not
in real danger quite yet but if he
wanted he could grab you and twist your
head off like a bottle cap what's with
the huge guy you ask us more than a
little concern in your voice oh him we
replied with the smirk he comes with the
anomaly he appears in every
scp-1893 experience to an extent though
his level of involvement varies if
scp-1893 doesn't perceive you as an
annoyance or a threat then you're good
to go but if 1893 starts to feel like
you're gonna cause it some problems then
the guy with the horn tattoos is going
to intervene speaking of which you look
up and you see that the giant man is now
standing next to you brow furrowed
invisible rage he picks up your drink
and crushes the glass in his hand
without flinching dripping booze and
blood onto the counter he snarls I think
you've had enough buddy now it's time
for you to leave or we're gonna have to
get physical the you don't need to be
told twice you grab your hat get up and
leave the bar abandoning us on our
lonely stool but our next info Hazard
still awaits you like poetry Japanese
poetry yes
The Humble Haiku it's dear 931 a unique
info Hazard it's so poetic though
specifically it takes the form of haiku
so what does that mean a rigid structure
the first line five syllables then seven
then five we can't talk about this in
ways other than Haiku it is challenging
object class is safe it is kept at site
19. need third tier clearance so what is
this thing
scp-931 it is a rice bowl white with a
blue band and a cracked blue pattern all
inside the bowl and we must confess we
took that one from the file man haikus
are hard three inches in height 4.5
inches across metric doesn't fit no
Maker's Marks found suspected to have
been made late 1900s really makes you
think on the skill of these poets Sans
anomalies sure it can't kill you but
writing these drives you mad curse 931
trapped in this Rhythm scheme makes the
old man's torture world look like a
resort okay let's move on other scps to
see were sick of haiku okay back to
normal time to shake off the structures
of scp-931 and talk about another iconic
info Hazard
scp-3007 this incurable info Hazard is a
lot less Whimsical than a rice bowl that
forces you to write and speak in Haiku
in fact it's literally killed seven
people and some unsurprisingly gruesome
ways the main component of the info
Hazard is known as
scp-3007-1 this is an extremely Vivid
anomalous hallucination that affects
those under the 3007 umbrella known as
scp-3007-2 to be afflicted with scp-3007
is a truly horrifying and debilitating
condition the hallucinations occur at an
average of four times a day with each
episode lasting for as long as an hour
and during these episodes the victims
are at risk of Grievous bodily harm or
even death so the question now is what
exactly is the scp-3007-1 hallucination
to the people experiencing it they
appear to be transported to a strange
alien world consisting of a huge number
of White Towers or pillars stretching
into the sky
scp-3007-2 specimens are trapped on a
series of bridges incredibly far off the
ground that connect these various
structures this anomalous area is known
as
scp-3007-3 it is important to remember
that people transported to this world
still remain physically in our own
however any damage sustained with
scp-3007-3 will carry over into our own
reality to give one particularly
gruesome example some people fall from
the carius Bridges and tumbled to their
deaths in
scp-3007-3 back in our reality they
suddenly explode from the damage of an
invisible high-speed impact killing them
instantly there's much more to scp-3007
enough that it probably warrants its own
explanation and the SCP Foundation takes
it extremely seriously believing that if
the info Hazard is allowed to breach
containment and become contagious it
could result in an XK Class end of the
world scenario as a result anyone found
to be infected by scp-3007 is contained
and summarily terminated to reduce the
risk of its spreading to make things
even worse there are also concerns about
scp-3007-3 seeping into our reality as
those standing within a 2 meter range of
scp-3007-2 during a 3007-1 episode can
actually hear the sounds from the
terrifying hallucinatory reality okay
that was a little scary how about
instead of falling to your death without
falling at all we talk about a nice
movie gonershrav by Martin Scorsese one
of the best gangster movies of all time
wait you've never heard of ganeshraf
it's got everything action suspense
romance a mountain of black thorns on
which lives a dark Tyrone of terrible
and unknowable power you sure you've
never seen ganeshrev well here's the
thing all signs point to movies like
garnish revs and many others simply not
existing this comes as a result of
scp-2747 an info hazardous phenomenon
that causes people to talk about works
of fiction that don't exist these Works
often feature commonalities like an
ethereal or disturbing tone ambiguity
black thorns and a Sinister mysterious
antagonist the foundation is doing all
they can to hunt down and suppress
scp-2747 but it's proving more difficult
than they'd imagined currently the
leading hypothesis is that these Tales
may have actually existed once but were
erased from reality leaving only the
residue of memory and the odd scrap of
evidence around many researchers
speculate that the various pieces that
form
scp-2747 are Ana fabula pieces of
fiction accidentally composed with the
perfect elements to cause them to quite
literally erase themselves over time now
the greatest concern that the foundation
has about these Ana fabulas is that they
might actually be one and their reality
is on the precipice of collapse but we
really don't have time to unpack that
right now and like
scp-3007 a full explanation of this
anomaly would take some time and is
probably best tackled on its own but
there you have it folks info hazards
they all say that knowing is half the
battle but in this case it is the whole
battle and if you know you lose not
really a battle at all come to think of
it more of uh trap but whether it's a
vicious Mega fish a strangely buffed man
with bull tattoos a poetic rice bowl or
a nightmarish ordeal of daily
hallucination there is no doubt that
info hazards are some of the most
strange and fascinating anomalies that
the foundation has to offer oh and of
course how could we forget the most
well-known info Hazard of all
scp-2521 this entity is so info
hazardous that its foundation file entry
is written in pictograms this is because
whenever information is recorded about
this entity it manifests and steals it
if you write it down it'll take the
paper if you make a note of it on a
computer it'll take the computer and of
course if you talk about it it'll
oh no no no no no no no
no
oh that was a close one
but I'm okay
for now at least agent Carla Mendoza was
one of the best field agents that site
41 had ever seen she was professional
cool under pressure and when the
situation demanded it she could be a
straight up badass during a chaos
Insurgency raid on the site she'd
single-handedly killed four different
insurgents the last one with her bare
hands during containment breaches she'd
always be the first one charging Into
The Fray her foundation standard issue
Beretta drawn and ready to fire agent
Mendoza was so devoted to the job that
she took up the psych director's offer
to start living on site so she could
always be there to help if an emergency
situation unfolded after all when it all
hits the fan you want someone as utterly
unshakable as agent Mendoza on your side
the job had thrown the worst of the
worst at her and she'd never even
flinched so surely nothing could scare
agent Mendoza right after a long day of
kick talking ass taking names and
filling in the properly mandated amount
of SCP Foundation debriefing paperwork
agent Mendoza retired to her site-41
quarters she felt exhausted and sweaty
so before heading to bed to watch some
wonderful SCP explained videos on her
phone how kind she decided to take a
quick shower the last thing she expected
was for this particular shower to become
well let's say hitchcockian the water
was running hot and clean filling the
air with steam agent Mendoza was
lathering up her hair when she first
heard the noise heavy wheezing breaths
coming from just behind the shower
curtain the second she heard it agent
Mendoza felt a kind of brutal crushing
anxiety that she'd never experienced
before like a hand was reaching into her
chest and squeezing her heart the
self-defense training that had been
encoded into her muscle memory over
years of working at the foundation
kicked into effect in a blind panic
she's struck out at the shower curtain
causing it to sway outwards and land
directly on the face of Mendoza's
wheezing voyeur who or whatever it was
it was standing right there less than a
meter away from the shower the wheezing
carved into Mendoza's ears like a
butcher's knife what an awful monstrous
sound and despite the fact that the
shower curtain obscured its face she
could still somehow see it the way a
defenseless animal can sense an
approaching Predator without ever
locking eyes on it and just somehow know
that it's too late for them to escape
now every training session every
achievement every piece of battle
hardening experience it all evaporated
in the presence of that thing Mendoza
was so terrified she might as well have
been a child the monster just stood
there beyond the curtain its raw fleshy
face parted into a freakishly wide
yellow-toothed grin she didn't know how
but on some deep primer level she was
aware that if this thing got its hands
on her something horrific Beyond
description would happen to her she was
too terrified to even move a muscle in
its presence she remained like that
standing in the shower and sobbing
quietly for the next three solid hours
until the creature finally disappeared
when her colleagues found her she'd
experienced moderate scalding wounds
from the hot water of the shower it took
several hours for agent Mendoza to
compose herself enough to share her
story a couple days later Tim Ellis a
junior level filing clerk was found
trapped in a site-41 Supply Closet he'd
urinated in his foundation issued slacks
and was in a state of borderline
Catatonia when his superiors asked him
why he'd been spending two hours in a
Supply Closet on company time he
reported that it was because a monster
had appeared outside the door when he
was searching for a replacement stapler
despite never actually opening the door
to see what was outside or call for help
Mr Ellis said that he felt as though he
would have had a heart attack if he
actually opened that accursed door he
was able to provide a clear description
of the monster he said it was tall and
emaciated with reddish brown skin that
made it seem almost burnt or rotten
while it stood there and waited beyond
the supply closet door it let out the
most awful wheezing noise like an old
rusty iron lung but the image that Ellis
seemed most fixated on was the monster's
face or lack thereof just a huge
grinning mouth that covered up its
entire head stocked with an arsenal of
massive yellow teeth Ellis was visibly
shivering as he talked about it two
incidents are an unpleasant coincidence
but three are a bona fide pattern and it
didn't take long for more sightings of
this strange new anomaly dubbed scp-303
or the doorman to pop up across the site
it earned that name by always appearing
behind some kind of doorway or at least
a movable divider in the case of agent
Mendoza's shower curtain whenever it
appeared outside a doorway nearby
Foundation Personnel would report being
struck with a sudden paralyzing Terror
that made engaging with the creature
impossible attempts to call for help
were also often stifled as the very
presence of the doorman causes
disruptions to electrical equipment
whenever the doorman manifests in your
proximity it's safe to say that it'll be
commanding your absolute undivided
attention this was a particularly
frightening case for the SCP Foundation
because it was one of the few anomalies
bringing the fight directly to them most
sentient anomalous beings would do
anything to avoid getting captured by
the SCP Foundation and contained in one
of their high security sites full of
experienced researchers and
state-of-the-art Equipment designed
specifically to neutralize their effects
the doorman however just seemed to take
this as a challenge turning even the
most hardcore Personnel on the site into
gibbering wrecks with its mere presence
but the doorman was just getting started
agent Henderson had a frightening
encounter in the break room he was
pulling a long shift and just wanted to
grab some coffee creamer from the
cabinet however as he approached the
cabinet he heard The Telltale wheezing
in that terrible overwhelming Terror set
in once more the doorman was sitting
inside the cabinet in a fetal position
he just knew it could this thing really
appear just anywhere as it pleased and
keep people in or out until it decided
to dematerialize and torment somebody
else when the creature finally
dematerialized and the cabinet was
examined the coffee creamer was found to
be missing leaving agent Henderson
distraught this was the first recorded
instance of the doorman stealing a
physical item but it would be far from
the last Henderson wondered whether the
creature that had just humiliated him
was sitting somewhere else now sipping
from a warm cup of joe with its big
freak mouth and laughing at him but a
few incidents after this things would
become considerably more serious the
doorman was about to take its first life
well it isn't really that simple if you
want to get into the semantics of the
thing when the body of Dr Barker was
found inside the second floor storage
room after a spree of scp-303 incidents
the question was naturally posed as to
whether the doorman had gotten more
dangerous and finally directly attacked
one of its victims not quite there had
only been one way in and out of the
storage room a secure decompression
chamber and the doorman had appeared
inside this chamber while Dr Barker was
in the storage room effectively trapping
him inside with the sheer Terror it
causes in its victims it was trapped in
the room for a grand total of five days
at which point he finally died of
dehydration and the doorman demanifested
shortly afterward the staff of site 41
scaled up their countermeasure efforts
hoping to discover more about and
perhaps even trap and contain the
infamous doorman Dr Burroughs researcher
Matthews four members of security
personnel and four d-class operatives
formed a kind of Strike Team ready for
quick dispatches whenever the doorman
happened to manifest it wasn't long
before the creature appeared in a room
on the first floor but the team quickly
intercepted its location ready and eager
to gather more data on the mysterious
being that had been terrorizing them all
for weeks Dr Burroughs ordered one of
the d-classes to open the door and look
inside but the d-class refused out of
fear the doctor told him that if he
didn't open the door he'd be transferred
to scp-682 duty the d-class frantically
shook his head and said I'd rather take
my chances with the reptile than go in
there the doctor was getting frustrated
he told the d-class that if he didn't
open the door immediately he'd be
terminated right there on the spot the
d-class still refused saying that he'd
take death over what the doorman would
do to him if he stepped in side without
hesitation Dr Burrows ordered one of the
security officers to shoot the d-class
then and there the shot was fired the
d-class was terminated Dr Burroughs then
ordered a female d-class who just
witnessed this callous execution to open
the door or the same abrupt death would
befall her she still refused then began
to describe the awful things she
believed the doorman would do to her if
she went inside researcher Matthews was
visibly shaken by the description Dr
Burroughs decided not to terminate this
d-class immediately he instead wanted to
see just how much pressure the doorman's
anomalous fear-based resistance
mechanisms could take another d-class
was given a combat knife and also given
the order to cut the female d-class with
it every time she refused and ordered to
go inside after two hours of repeated
asking from Dr Burrows the female
d-class dropped dead from blood loss at
no point did she ever attempt to open
the door it seemed that in all the cases
for those in the thrall of the dormant's
anomalous effects death is a truly
preferable alternative to ever facing it
head on it's worth mentioning that these
tests were conducted back in the 1970s
before the formation of the foundation's
Ethics Committee which explains why
their methods feel a little needlessly
cruel since then the doorman has fully
commandeered the second floor storage
room the same one where it caused Dr
Barker's death it only leaves the room
to steal more items from around the site
these items have included a cryotube
three sets of standard foundation
surgical equipment two d-class research
cadavers one gasoline-powered generator
a variety of chemicals from the chemical
storage areas and of course poor agent
Henderson's can of powdered coffee
creamer the reason for the doorman
taking an interest in these particular
items remains unknown but we can only
assume that nothing good can come of it
and there you have it folks the strange
frightening and eerily inconclusive tale
of the doorman all we can really say is
that we're awfully glad he's fixated on
bothering site 41 because who knows what
would happen if he widened his net to
the rest of us thankfully we won't need
to think about that oh that's odd can
you hear that I thought I was imagining
it they'll come to think of it I can't
help but feel a little uneasy right now
do you ever get that feeling that you're
being watched wait the door there's
something behind the door can you feel
it can you feel its red flesh and rotten
teeth pressing up against it breathing
waiting Can you feel it staring at you
without eyes looking deep into your very
Soul well that's good but just stay
cautious okay after all life has many
doors head boy and you never know who or
what will be waiting for you behind the
next one growing up in a small Virginia
Town near the mountains right on the
border of West Virginia Zane heard all
kinds of stories from his grandmother
Tales of mountain lions who could
transform into ghostly women the talipo
a fluffy rodent-like creature on an
endless quest to get its tail back from
the hunter who took it the Mothman that
appeared with glowing red eyes to warn
of impending tragedy most of all she
warned him about the deer sometimes she
used to say when you're out in the woods
late at night you'll see a deer acting a
little bit funny maybe it's making
strange sounds maybe it's standing up
like a man maybe it's staring at you
from the shadows and won't look away if
you ever see one of these deer promise
me you'll get away from it as fast as
possible don't look at it don't talk to
it just get far far away he promised her
every time but as he got older he
started to forget his grandma's stories
letting them fade away with memories of
the Easter Bunny and Santa Claus he
didn't think about the stories again
until he was older a junior in college
and embarking on a camping trip with his
roommate Josh they were both staying
with Zayn's family for the summer and
had been enjoying the sunshine and fresh
air they'd gone hiking picked black
berries and gone fishing to their hearts
content after a while they got sick of
sleeping in the cramped house and
decided to have a proper camping trip
out in the mountains campsites were
crowded this time of year but Zane knew
a spot just isolated enough that they
could kick back enjoy nature and relax
in peace they packed their supplies and
headed out into the forest for a weekend
they would never forget by Nightfall
Zane and Josh had pitched their tents
built a fire and were starting to make
some dinner they roasted hot dogs and
heated cans of beans over the fire and
decided to start telling some classic
scary stories sitting by the crackling
fire listening to the rustling leaves
snapping twigs and the chittering of
animals all around Zayn couldn't help
but remember the stories he had almost
forgotten all the strange inexplicable
things that came out after the sun went
down and the forest went quiet he
thought he could hear the footsteps of
something walking by their campsite
circling them but it was probably just
as in imagination as Josh told stories
about babysitters stalked by Killers and
drivers picking up ghostly hitchhikers
Zane was thinking about the deer he
shuddered but shook it off and after
some more stories and a few too many
s'mores the two friends decided to get
some sleep after several hours Zane woke
to the sound of Josh unzipping his tent
he sat up ready to yell at his friend
for waking him up but the sight of
Josh's pale frightened face stopped him
there's something here was all Josh
could say his hands Zane noticed were
shaking hey man it's it's okay let's
check it out Zane patted Josh on the
shoulder he was pretty sure his friend
just wasn't used to camping in actual
nature but reach for his hunting knife
just in case he grabbed a flashlight and
switched it on following Josh out into
the darkness he swept the beam across
the clearing and it illuminated a pair
of orange eyes staring directly at him
from behind a nearby tree what the he
approached the shape trying to get a
clear look at it as it became more
illuminated his stomach dropped it was a
deer but something was wrong with it its
mouth was wide open its jaw working up
and down like it was trying to make a
sound but nothing came out but that
wasn't the worst part as the flashlight
beam illuminated the animal's body Zayn
realized that somehow its head was on
backwards what the Josh appeared behind
him gasping shh Zane shushed him
intensely he suddenly remembered his
grandmother's warnings you know what I
don't feel so great I think we should go
back to the car and head to my place he
gave Josh a look shaking his head as if
to say don't say another word by the
glow of their flashlights the two packed
up their campsite all under the Gaze of
the misshapen deer they drove home in
silence Josh only speaking once to ask
what was that thing Zayn shook his head
I don't know but it wasn't a deer they
crept back into the house and went to
bed they knew they would never speak of
tonight ever again as Zane began to
Drift Off to Sleep his last conscious
thought was to glance out the window
there in the yard not five feet away was
a deer watching he didn't know it but
that night Zane encountered an instance
of
scp-6448
scp-6448 is an anomalous species of
creatures that appear to belong to the
server Day family nicknamed the not deer
they are highly Intel and can be
distinguished from ordinary deer by
unusual behavior and physical
deformities some of these have included
legs that bend backwards the eyes of an
animal other than deer forward-facing
eyes jerking movements lack of fear
towards humans and walking on two hind
legs most notably and most frightening
scp-6448 instances will watch and stalk
humans for a duration of hours or even
days they will follow humans home and
steal items from their domains including
weapons food and other personal items
they're most frequently found in the
Deep Woods at night when a person is
completely alone if someone encounters
an instance of
scp-6448 if they acknowledge any of the
creature's anomalous traits it will
attack in order to limit the loss of
life and ensure that the SCP Foundation
employees exercise the utmost caution
when dealing with
scp-6448 the cryptozoology division
issued the following guidelines if you
notice a deer that seems off look away
and ignore it if it knows that you've
noticed it it's too late if you hear
your name whistling or something else in
the woods calling for you don't
acknowledge it never acknowledge it
exists don't respond don't go looking
for it don't call back to it if you're
walking at night and you feel something
breathing on your neck or Whispering
behind you the key to your safety is
pretending that everything is normal
your survival is dependent on your
ignorance whatever
scp-6448 is they appear to be
intelligent enough to understand when
they are being studied and they don't
seem to like it very much on January 11
1994 a group of three
scp-6448 instances broke into site-41 in
North Carolina using a tunnel they had
carved over a long period of time at the
time there was an instant containment
but in all the chaos of the breach the
specimen was lost every time an instance
was captured and contained near
scp-6448's habitat he would later Escape
via similar tunnels
scp-6448 was officially classified by
the SCP Foundation in 1980 but those
from the Appalachian region have known
about these strange creatures since at
least
1947. from folk tales and campfire
stories to Second Hand and even
first-hand encounters the locals are
aware of the not deer's existence and
are largely familiar with the
precautions necessary to avoid them
though many of the civilians that
encounter
scp-6448 avoid notifying the authorities
there have been several recorded 9-1-1
calls involving the not deer since 2000.
the following is a log of those calls
February 1st 2000 victim age 41 female
dialed Emergency Services after hearing
their name being called from the woods
near their home the victim recounts the
vocalization being likened to a scream
and a voice that they do not recognize
and requested assistance in locating the
source emergency Personnel requested the
subject Place their phone on the floor
outside the home to listen for the
alleged sounds after two minutes a
vocalization was heard that was calling
to the subject by name emanating from
the nearby Forest the subject was
instructed to investigate the
disturbance themselves and keep Services
updated on the situation the victim then
began to walk into the Woodland getting
about 50 meters into the underbrush
before inexplicably stopping they claim
there to be a noticeably large deer
standing in the way of the path she
begins to walk closer those States it
does not move subject diverts From the
Path and begins walking in a different
direction after 30 minutes no source of
the voice is determined the caller
returns to the residence June 13 2002
victim age 28 male calls 9-1-1 regarding
a home break-in the caller notes
numerous items to be missing from their
residents and requests and investigation
operators dispatched two investigators
to visit the home and and pertain a
potential perpetrator the pair note that
based on earlier CCTV images all Cutlery
sharp objects Firearms light bulbs and a
single copy of the novel The Day After
Roswell are missing also noted is that
there is a complete lack of any
fingerprints at the scene with no doors
or Windows having been broken into
analysis of the home CCTV footage
revealed there to be a two-hour period
of missing film with the exception of a
single frame containing a service Nippon
on its hind legs reaching towards the
camera its frontal Hooves have been
warped to resemble fingers no footage of
the entity exiting the home was
discovered November 19 2005 a cattle
farmer age 54 male reported to local
authorities the sudden disappearance of
of over 30 percent of his largest herd
response teams surged the nearby area
for four hours though found no trace of
his cattle the victim was recommended to
set up trail cameras and note any
unusual activity overnight at 1 11 am
two
scp-6448 are seen walking through the
field before fleeing one places an
object into the ground later discovered
to be a single Fork a week after this
discovery 200 discarded bovine Hooves
appear at the location March 4th 2009
victim age unknown gender unknown dials
9-1-1 to request assistance from Animal
Services the victim is standing within a
forest in front of a service elephus
which is violently contorting the victim
attempts to State you better get a vet
or something I don't think it's well
before piercing Screech is heard and the
line Falls silent recovered footage
depicts the aforementioned animal
squirming seemingly in pain a vicious
churning is audible as a black mass
erupts out of to the instance and the
video turns to static October 11 2012
victim age 23 male is a junior Wildlife
officer at the Cherokee National Forest
Tennessee they radioed their supervisor
in the early morning regarding a herd of
undecolius virginius within the reserve
supposedly there is a single animal that
upon first glance appears average though
possesses Divergent attributes including
backwards joints enlarged abdomen and
forward-facing Eyes Upon stating this a
distant whistle is audible the victim
stumbles slightly they begin to say what
the did it just whistle at me before the
sound of hooves rapidly getting closer
is heard notably the hoof steps did not
sound to be in the traditional Gallop of
a servid October 12 2012 the former
victim supervisor calls authorities
following the victim's absence from The
Reserve Night Shift following this the
radio begins to crackle the victim's
voice can be heard on the other end a
requests these supervisor's attention he
calls regarding a herd of odacolius
virginius within the reserve they claim
there is a single animal that upon first
glance appears average though possesses
Divergent attributes including backwards
joints enlarged abdomen and
forward-facing eyes suspecting the
creature to be a rare genetic
malformation the victim requests their
supervisor to come to the location the
supervisor questions the victim about
what happened the night previous there
is no reply upon the supervisors and law
enforcement's arrival at the site a herd
of approximately 80 oticolius virginius
was present a single entity is in the
field Center and appears to be standing
separate from the rest of the group it
flees the scene upon realizing the law
enforcement's presence where it formally
stood lay a standard two-way radio April
8 2016. victim age 35 female dials 9-1-1
using a satellite phone distressed they
State they are in redactive County Woods
and are being followed she claims that
despite seeing no one for the duration
of her hike she quote feels as if she's
being watched and has heard someone
walking behind her at various points in
the Trap the victim is unable to give an
adequate description of their location
but knows the route to return to her
residence operators request the victim
to return to a point wherein she can
provide a sufficient Geographic
description of her position the victim
remains on the line for the duration of
the hike back to a readily used portion
of the Wilderness Trail along the
journey various unnatural sounds can be
heard these include footsteps Rock
slides coughing whispering and whistling
nearing the main trail all Woodland
noises such as birds and winds see
suddenly and the victims State she can
see a malformed deer carcass coated in a
thick layer of black slime at this time
human screams can be heard in the
distance operators request the victim
continue and ignore the other stimuli
agents embedded in local law enforcement
suspecting SC
p6448 involved notified gamma 4 to the
situation 20 minutes later the victim
returns to the main trail gamma 4 now
operating the 9-1-1 call informs the
victim not to respond to any further
unusual activity and greatly outlines
service protocol for the duration of the
victim's journey to her home two sets of
breathing are audible the victim
successfully returns to her residence
and shuts the door behind her now out of
sight from
scp-6448 Agents inquire of the victim's
address and the victim promptly complies
operatives instruct the victim to have
possession of all firearms and weapons
on the premises and to barricade herself
inside a safe space with one exit point
the victim swiftly begins grabbing all
available weapons and throwing them
inside a wardrobe it is at this time
there's a knock on the front door the
victim does not respond and continues to
hoard sharp objects from kitchen drawers
the knocking becomes more violent as the
handle is jostled and is shaken
incessantly a voice on the other side
side repeats the phrase hello it is me
hello let me in in a calm manner as the
door begins to shake the victim retreats
to her wardrobe armed with a small
firearm upon sealing herself in the
space the knocking ceases and footsteps
can be heard becoming further away the
sound of Galloping is audible as the
front door caves in hoof steps can now
be heard inside the home The Entity
continues to repeat hello it is me hello
let me in as it searches the small
building a bright light flashes overhead
seemingly circling the house eventually
The Entity enters the victim's bedroom
through a small slit in the wardrobe
door the victim can see a service
canadensis standing on its hind legs and
surveying the room its movements are
crooked and stiff seeming to struggle to
stand in a bipedal fashion it slouches
down to a quadrupedal Crouch similar to
The Stance of an arachnid it inhales
heavily and its head locks on the view
of the Wardrobe it is noted as
possessing human eyes it scampers
towards the subject and opens the door a
single gunshot is heard responders found
no trace of either
scp-6448 or the victim containment of
scp-6448 is focused on the investigation
of any deer exhibiting anomalous traits
in and around the Appalachian area any
civilian sightings of
scp-6448 are to be handled by mobile
task force gamma 4 or the green Stags
any possible deaths resulting from
scp-6448 will be blamed on hiking
accidents and any reported sightings can
be explained away with chronic wasting
disease CWD occasionally referred to as
zombie deer disease is a prion disease
affecting members of the server Day
family symptoms of the illness include
loss of motor function control and
damage to decision-making as well as
gradual degradation of all mental
faculties it is 100 fatal however though
the disease these does exist most
recorded cases of it in the Appalachian
region can actually be attributed to
instances of
scp-6448 any captured instances of
scp-6448 should be transported to
site-44 for the cryptozoology division's
containment and study on November 29
2019 they finally got their chance to
bring a not deer into custody the green
Stags were able to capture an instance
of
scp-6448 with the help from MTF new 7
hammer down and their heavy Vehicles
Division as well as some experimental
shock rifles one not deer was knocked
unconscious in the conflict and its body
was loaded onto an armored helicopter
and flown straight to site-44 in Essex
England at the site it was then placed
in a reinforced steel containment cell
and heavily sedated this entire process
went off without a hitch as the entity
began to regain Consciousness
cryptozoology specialist F Oz watched it
through a one-way glass window and
attempted to speak to it through the
intercom greetings
scp-6448 researcher odds began at the
sound of his voice the creature jumped
to its feet staring at the intercom can
you understand me we've seen your genus
speak English just fine in the past the
animal did not answer but began licking
one of its legs and behaving as if it
were an ordinary deer researcher outside
impatiently please we know your secret
the not deer stopped what it was doing
freezing completely still as it listened
to the words admittedly it wasn't
exactly well capped if you just look at
yourself for more than a few seconds it
is very clear that you're not normal at
this the creature which had been facing
away from the window swiveled its neck
180 degrees breaking its own spine with
an audible crack it stared unblinking at
the window and directly at researcher Oz
Oz turned to the containment staff
suddenly anxious I thought you said this
was one way the staff is assured him
that it was and there was no way the not
deer could see him still its eyes were
locked directly on his face he shook off
the sense of unease and continued his
line of questioning are you something
imitating dear it is clear that if so
you possess basic anatomical knowledge
of them though details are clearly
faulty in fact a better question would
be how if in fact you are not what you
pretend to be the not deer opened its
mouth at this revealing unusually sharp
teeth it moved its jaws if attempting to
speak but only a choking sound came out
shall we move on Oz asked but I'm more
concerned with here is why you take on
people is it a vendetta spiked food for
the first time in the interview the not
deer blinked it was an unnatural
movement forced and deliberate like the
creature was attempting to engage in an
ordinary Behavior rather than actually
experiencing an involuntary impulse
responding is mandatory researcher Oz
prompted the creature did not react if
you will not comply maz's tone grew
Stern frustrated maybe you'd like to see
your brand new containment cell at last
The Entity spoke dreams
Church its voice resembled the distorted
version of Oz's research what kind of Oz
wasn't able to finish his question July
7
1947 the creature said before ramming
into the one-way glass and cracking it
azaz stumbled backwards from the force
the creature collapsed on the ground
seizing and screaming as its abdomen get
the Stags in here now Oz cried out but
it was too late the black mass of
something shiny and tendered leaped out
of the not deer scuttling around the
cell before shattering the window and
leaving the empty shell of a deer behind
the site-44 breach system activated and
attempted to initiate emergency
containment protocols but the mysterious
black mass escaped its sector made its
way toward the main exit broke through
the glass of the front exit door and
vanished into the Shrubbery outside the
escaped anomaly could not be found and
recontained ever since this incident
there have been a record-breaking number
of chronic wasting disease cases
identified in Deer here in the
surrounding area as well as an
unprecedented increase in UFO reports
further research is currently ongoing
but it is unknown whether we will ever
truly know what these creatures are only
one thing is for certain they are
definitely not dear now go check out
scp-968 sleep killer and scp-2571
cracklewood park for more anomalies that
I'm sure you'll never want to sleep
again wait is that a deer behind you oh